guys I am signing a PS5 why because
we're giving it away I did this side
Marty's going to sign this side so we
don't disrespect this PlayStation since
it's Christmas PS5 giveaway signed by
who Grand Theft Auto Franklin Sean
fontino
and a copy of Grand Auto 5 signed by
Franklin Shan vont we just did the
episode guys and we're like you know
what it's Christmas let's do something
for the fans and for the fans out there
if you don't like my trash signature
just leave it on this side okay that's
why I did it on the back sign on the
inside sign on the outside sign on here
sign on here sign on here all right
we're shipping this off to one lucky
winner thank you guys so much for
supporting thank you for supporting the
show have a dope ass day Merry
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect
perfect yo what's up everybody I am
Thomas dope as Yol welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast I'm here with my
co-host Mar O'Neal folks guys let's get
straight into it all right this is
installment to but I feel like this is
the start this is the Shan fontino this
is solo Franklin whatever you want to
call however you want to address him
this is this this is the G this is the
GTA episode let's get started let's go
let's get started highly anticipated I'm
I'm exced yes sir I'm here man [__] you
know I come for you dog all the time
apprciate bro I appreciate you don't do
a lot of interviews at all I was
searching around on YouTube not a lot
out there so we really appreciate that I
don't but I I I'd be wanting to do more
but some [__] they just yeah
when I act when they calling me and if
you look at my emails bro they full of
people man IGN all these people want to
do interviews and I
just can imagine cuz all you can do is
keep asking me the same [__] same [__]
and I'm going keep answering the same
old [__] same old [__] so when I come
with y'all man you know we can talk
about different [__] cuz you know I can
just open up to y'all you know cuz y'all
the only show that I opened up to the
last time about my drug addiction about
um um the mental you know awareness and
[__] of me wantan to commit y'all the
only ones did that bro that I felt
comfortable with talking to y'all about
other than that I don't talk to people
about that [__] man I watched back the
episode and just it was super impactful
man I look through all the comment and
we do all the time I don't know if you
saw it but there's a lot like you were
saying I wish I could just hug this man
that help me through step by step
watching that's the same thing the same
reception that you were giving telling
you just read read some of the comments
people have I got it this morning I'm
going through op withraw day four thank
God for this episode yeah like it really
does mean something man it do it mean a
lot bro cuz that's how I got through my
addiction was looking at a dude on
YouTube day for day and he was giving me
encouragement and hope that you can get
to the finish line so if I could do it
for people um it's all put it this way
it's almost like I want to start taking
pills again just to get addicted again
cuz I used to love the feeling that [__]
used to feel good even it's to help the
pain too but I also want to kick it
again but then document myself kicking
it again so people can see exactly what
you go through cuz if you never went
through kicking drugs bro for some
reason opiate pills is [__] the worst
I know people that be on Heron I know
people be on
cocaine other type of drugs like lean
and [__] and they have just [__] up
stomach for a little while and throwing
up and diarrhea you know and they had
they stomach pains and they shakes but
man that goddamn opium man that
chemically made [__] white pill that
they make bro it does something to the
brain bro it's crazy bro I'm telling you
I'm telling you from experience of what
I went through with that and then I talk
to people that kicked like Heron and and
lean and they like ah I just had
diarrhea you know few sleepless nights
you know chills and [__] like that no I
had man all the worst [__] you can think
of putting somebody through like I
wanted to just kill my [__] self cuz
I didn't want to deal with that [__] you
know it was many days and hours and
minutes that I just want to say [__]
that man I need to [__] find a pill
so I can just to shake this [__] you
know what I'm saying but I fought it and
anybody that that take opiate pills man
Naros uh oxycotton and all that crazy
[__] man they would tell you it's the
worst [__] Bro the worst and did you go
for back surgery shortly after our last
episode yeah and they and they put me
back on some [__] called u u perco setes
or some [__] [__] man feel like
heaven you feel
like [__] that had to be scary though
like but I controlled it because I only
took it just to go to sleep I I I just
it was a a guy that I knew that was
going through he been through it many
times of just withdrawals just kicking
[__] and he said I told him I had the
surgery and I was like man I'm scared to
go have the surgery cuz they going to
put me on these pills and I don't want
to get back hooked on this [__] but you
have to take him for all this pain
you're going to be so I was in all this
[__] pain man and but they gave me
these pills and I said how do I beat
this addiction and not get addicted
again he said just take them when you go
to sleep right before you go to sleep
deal with the pain through the day lay
down and I said that's going to be hard
bro he was like just trust me do it that
way I didn't do it I went the other way
I took them I took them in the morning
when I got up I took it at lunch and I
took one at dinner right and then after
about four or five days the pain kind of
start subsiding and going away then I
said I'mma do it his way and I took it
right when I said I'm going to go to bed
turn the TV off took it that way you
don't crave the addiction you sleep
through it so you be painfree in your in
your sleep and you sleep good you wake
up and you be like damn you don't crave
it but if you taking it while you wide
awake it's an addiction feeli because
SLE yeah it just gives you that
everything just feel good the music
sound good the food tastes good just
that's what them pills does man these
[__] is smart man I'm not going
to say the name because them
[__] you'll pop up missing you
say you know what I'm saying them
[__] be like know you giving
Too Much Game get him up out of here so
but yeah um that addiction [__] is is
crazy man you know cuz it it also plays
a part on and this is something that I I
wanted I was glad to come back on here
talk to y'all to build off of the last
interview I did um the pills
addiction drugs alcohol it also plays a
strong connection man to this disease
that's caus Su and mental awareness
because it's it's a depression pill you
know what I'm saying this is something
you take to be not depressed you take
these pills to make you feel like all
everything is okay and then once you not
getting them or you get too used to this
one pill for so long it's like it's not
working no more so now you trying to
look for something stronger but what's
stronger nothing's really stronger you
can go to Heron you can go to oxycoton
you ain't doing them but just killing
yourself worse and worse so that's where
the suicide [__] come and then they say
[__] it I'm take all of them cuz I I'm
I'm chasing this High and a lot of
people man they just don't care like
like if you can't get them no more the
doctors don't give them to you like that
no more like right after I got my
surgery they only gave me like 15 of
them I was in pain for about a month and
a half so after the 15 when I got down
to about seven or six of them I called
the doctor I said hey man I'm down to
about six I'm going to need more cuz I'm
still in pain and stuff and they was
like we can't give you anymore so what
that forces you to do is your addiction
forces you to start calling friends and
calling people and now you buying them
from somebody on the street that could
have fentanyl in them and all kind of
[__] and that's where the deaths
come from I lost two people be because
of that man I got a [__] toothache
man a [__] toothache [__] this
[__] killing me and everybody
know a toothache bro yeah I mean I don't
know if everybody a lot of people
brushed their [__] and took care of
their [__] but too takes is I rather get
shot again then go through a bro them
[__] hurt because it's in your
nerve in your head in your brain you
feel what I'm saying I let a
[__] shoot me in the leg bro
before I deal with this [__] again bro I
dealt with it too many times so if it's
hurting that bad you will say man
anybody got some pills man I just need
something to get this pain away and
somebody be like yeah I bought something
from my boy on the street up the street
around the corner I got one here and it
[__] be laced with fentanyl next say
know fall asleep and never wake back up
so it's it's a dangerous game we play
man we gamble it's a gambling game when
you're addicted to anything that can be
laced with something that is deadly and
take you away because you chasing this
High bro I don't think that high is
worth it that much you know what I'm
saying go eat a bunch of [__]
chocolate you feel me dopamine kick in
yeah let that dopamine kick in go eat
something that gives you that same
[__] [__] go in the bathroom and beat
your [__] beat your meat or go have sex
or something because it gives you that
same [__] when you release you feel what
I'm saying that's a men and women if you
release that orgasm you get that same
[__] feeling think about it it's that
oh my
goding over yeah then you be but but but
that orgasm don't last long cuz you be
looking at him like man get the [__]
away for me man [__] you know after you
do it and that feeling come down man
don't put your feet on me man watch out
I do it sorry babe what camera is on uh
sorry babe my apology camera yeah yeah
yeah but um it is what it is man you
know but that that addiction man I I I
want to just do a a a whole segment on
like one day we can just talk just
strictly about that I don't want to
spend this interview on I want to do a
whole straight segment with someone else
man that that we can talk about this
mental Awareness stuff and we can run a
number across through the screen that's
saying hey contact this number for Heth
you know done that once yeah my daughter
goes to a really nice high school
there's kids dying in her school like
kids it's like a third kid already and
that's sad bro that's [__] sad
because of this [__] peill or this
drug done grab this baby and this baby
don't know no different it's like the
baby can't this little kid can't
function without these pills or this
drug to the point that she's don't even
know she's I'm not going to say she's
willing to die but she just don't know
none of us know you don't know when you
going to get a bad one or you don't know
when it's not going to work for you I
know the feel of of all damn near all
the side effects of taking these [__]
pills bro cuz I studied myself when I
was doing them stomach ache breathing
problems your blood pressure goes up um
um you get you get angry you [__]
angry with your family for nothing you
Snappy you just go through so many side
effects bro that it you can tell that
it's because of the drugs cuz once you
get off of them [__] man you be
like damn I'm happier stomach Don't Hurt
No More I don't have headaches I'm not
angry you know what I'm saying I'm all
cool so this [__] that's created is the
devil itself bro is is evil it's
probably worse than the devil man it's
[__] evil bro it's not right man you
know saying was the back surgery worth
it no I'm [__] mad that I got it bro
what was wrong with your back um I had
spine it was called um
um uh what you call that [__] man U
where your spine narrow um narrowing on
your um nerves spinal
stenosis and it came over years of just
like I used to be a Avid Runner I used
to jog and a lot bro I'm talking about I
used to go run 10 miles every morning
like nothing like just
gone my wife used to be like oh my God
why are you running so much and no sweat
coming I used to just be I don't know I
got addicted to this [__] I used to run
around the track bro constant like
nonstop bro and I think after all the
running and accidents I've been through
and then being shot twice in the stomach
and shot in the arms and just the [__] I
put myself through at a younger age it
catches up to you in life and when you
get to a certain age this older man said
why you doing all that running stop
[__] running walk don't run like that
no more you're going to pay for a nice
like shut the [__]
up I wish I would have listened to him
so it got to the point that it was so
bad that um I was like trying to find
pills for it again then I said I don't
want to do that so talking to the
doctors what do I do cuz they like we
give you some pills I don't want your
[__] pills what could we do to fix
this once and for all well we don't
recommend surgery right now we would say
wait till you get a little older but we
can do therapy okay let's try therapy
I'm in there with these people a old ass
lady or old man that really don't know
what the [__] they doing so you really
be in more pain when you come home after
the therapy session so you be like this
[__] was a waste you know what I'm
saying it's making it worse then you get
the injections the injections is the
only [__] that work cortisone whatever
the [__] they do bro they they lay you
on the table put a IV in your [__]
hand and you lay down and they say okay
here come your cocktail and they and you
hear the doctor say yeah give them uh
one cc two cc's of fentanyl you be like
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
on hold on hold on you be like no this
is the safe [__] man you you are in the
doctor
that's what Michael Jackson said yeah
bro I'm telling you so you be you kind
of being out of fear bro but you laying
down on the bed with all your clothes on
they just pull your shirt up and clean
right at the center where the where the
where the spine is at and they got a
x-ray machine to show where they go in
then shoot this [__] at and they pump
this [__] in you in your hand the lady
will be like okay come the cocktail and
you be like sitting there like mhm next
thing know you
be and it it they do it you don't feel
nothing next know they be okay come on
let's go call your wife um we walking
him out now you walk out to the car 2
hours later the high go
away um the pain be gone you be like
damn really gone [__] hell yeah you be
like what the [__] like feel brand new
and it might last for some people it
last for a year some people it last 6
months my [__] when I first started
doing
them um they were lasting for like 6
months to 8 months
talking about pain free bro pain [__]
free then it got to where it was only
lasting 3 months then it got to about a
month and a half so now it been
balancing around a month and a half to
two months like I had just got one in
um I want to say October early October
MH and the pain is back it's back you
know but we in December so I got a good
month and a half close to you know
almost two months but the pain is coming
back I didn't know you had back problems
man I have I don't know if you know I
have a severe back problem telling me
bro my shit's working I've been doing
this this decompression uh spinal
specialist bro I can touch my toes I can
bend to the side I can touch all that
[__] I can do that too bro saying no my
my back I couldn't I was at 5% Mobility
I could not B all my discs were yeah see
your rupt your disc your problem is your
disc on top each other yeah mine wasn't
that all that was
the of the where the nerves down your
brain down in theer of your was
Nar so the only thing they can do is say
hey we see it right here on the MRI at
your L4 L5 bom to cut you open open that
[__] up Cut Them Bones out you know you
have these things all down the back of
your spine you can feel them press back
there you can't feel my two they had to
cut cut off so it can relief the
pressure on the oh so you just have you
have it's a it's like a degenerative
thing with you yeah it's not oh damn got
bad not spasm and none of that [__] I
just end up with a bad look I can't
imagine this kind of pain this is
different pain that I like I really
supposed to squeezing the nerves
basically it's choking it and it runs
down both of your legs it just add to
your knees oh my God the worst pain bro
so I'm really supposed to be heavy on
drugs right now to be honest with you
but I fight it you know some things you
just learn to live with I'm just
adapting the pain and making it into
something else you know what I'm saying
I just take it in take it in take it so
you basically just have to manage that
manage it yeah yeah yeah yeah so I'm
managing that [__] and it's hard bro
it's not easy as y'all think it is like
like I dread going out to the game
tonight because so much walking makes it
worse bro and this weekend I got to go
to [__] Arizona to go to um to the
Cardinals in 49ers game and [__] and I'm
not neither one of they fans but I'm
just going because my agent got me and
the other um guy that play in Grand
Theft Auto we supposed to be going cuz
this big promoter he's the big shot out
there he want to invite us there to meet
the players and meet some people and
then Monday we going to do uh a giveaway
to uh the Children's Hospital the kids
with cancer and all that type of stuff
so I said well if it's for something
like that I'm going fight the pain and
I'mma go you know what I'm saying and
I'm paying out my own pocket with it you
know what I'm
saying [__] yeah yeah just giving my
charity back you know end of the year
doing my [__] I write the [__] off
whatever it is but yeah man I deal with
[__] all the time I didn't know you had
back pain like that man [__] when you
see me bro in August bro I couldn't get
up my stairs I remember my legs like
shut off I saw you on your thing the
[__] you was just dealing with you was
going through the man I didn't know you
had it like that though that's why I fa
your pain bro I feel your [__] pain
my wife's in the same bow right now with
the nerves like the discs pressing on
her nerves she's been going for the
shots didn't work all the decompression
sh therapy not working so it's like yeah
you resort to some medication man that's
the only [__] to take your mind from it
and it's a dangerous game to play but
[__] we need it we don't have we don't
have nothing else and they not going to
fix you bro I'm learning that now unless
you go out of the country and get the
[__] done or you go and find a like I
found this doctor in Dallas it's a black
dude said man come here and get fixed
[__] this being a a cash cow for these
doctors bro they're not never going to
fix you they going to put a Band-Aid get
you long enough to come back again get
another cuz every time you go under that
knife bro that's 300,000 350 that your
insurance is paying and then I got to
pay my deductible and all so it's why
fixing when we can keep this [__] going
now imagine doing that [__] with all the
billions of people on the
Earth yeah some I mean I get it I get
why they would do it but
every one of those people was a kid one
day and go you know you're going to grow
up to be a piece of [__] that's why I
think how can you live yeah that's
that's terrible so so at the end of the
day I don't I I I I nag about the [__]
and I I [__] about it sometime but all
the [__] I escaped through life you know
growing up not supposed to make 18 vers
it was 16 18 21 25 and I surpassed all
all of that [__] I done have kids that
kids didn't have kids and and still
going married 27 years and still
moving how dare I complain I could talk
about it but how dare do I [__]
complain bro deal with this pain just
deal with it it comes with what you what
you just been dealing with all your life
you just escaped it at a younger age now
you at a age you know what I'm saying
where you can try to figure a way to
deal with it but you could have been in
a wheelchair this whole time I could
have been in I could have been dead I
could have been in jail life bro the
[__] my lifestyle I could have been
definitely dead or in jail for Life bro
them two it wasn't no other option when
I was coming up bro I lived a [__]
dangerous life bro I did I did bro I'm
telling you I kept a [__] gun on me
24/7 in church in the mall in the
grocery store I didn't give a [__] cuz
that's the life I live when you out here
pedaling that [__] you have to and you
are a big wig at a young age like I told
y'all in the last [__] I went through
two kidnapping y'all don't know that
feeling you know right now your [__]
phone ringing you I got to take this car
man and a [__] answer the phone
and say man how much you want to spend
to get your wife
back you you take it as a joke like oh
man it's a [__] wrong number and they
call back again how much do you want to
spend to get your [__] girl back like
man then it just start registering hold
on let me see something you call her job
she's de every [__] day and you call
her job she didn't make it in today she
hasn't checked in or nothing reality
starts setting in this is real it's
finally happening to you and this is
when kidnapping was at a all time
[__] high in the streets of LA if you
was any dude getting any kind of money
it was happening and it happened to me
twice [__] twice bro I mean the first
time it was my son's
mother we got her back
with little bit of Confrontation but
when they find out who they was [__]
with they it was a wild story in the
book about the the I don't know how much
you want to I don't know how much you
want to get but bro the book is going to
be a movie I can see it already one day
wow I got somebody right now trying to
trying to do it yeah this Asian dude
that got a lot of uh investors said they
can go straight to Netflix with it they
want to it's a SC it's a scary thing to
do though it's a touchy it was scared to
do that it was real scary to do just
that and that [__] is watered down to
like you take 100% And you dilute it and
make it only 10% bro and that's still
shaky to this was wild as hell of course
come on that's not that's tip of the
iceberg bro so when you start talking
about selling your life rights to these
other people and they give you some
money for it I don't think my life R is
worth no amount of dollar bro because
the demons you open up and the
[__] come to collect and I
don't want to open sometime you just
want to keep them closed bro say hey hey
I'm cool with life bro N I don't want to
do no no biop picking no whatever y'all
talking about doing you know what I'm
saying I actually turned this [__] down
day before yesterday and they was like
well can you just come on to this big
podcast and blah blah blah and this and
that and I said not to talk about that
what do y'all want me to talk about and
they was like well we want to talk about
mental awareness and [__] like that but
I know they trying to be slick and I
said yeah how much y'all going to pay me
and they want to throw some money okay
throw the money but I'm going come and
I'm going dictate how to interview go M
cuz you're not going to ask me about
what you want to ask me about when it
comes to my lifestyle I gave you as much
as I could out of it cuz you got that
book was like this bro first and I was
telling my the writer uh Yousef that
that that uh that that we
couldn't we can't we it seems like you
picked a couple big stories that's what
it felt
like and cleaned them up and washed them
got them in there got my attorney to
look at it is that okay he was like cuz
you should have seen it at first he was
like oh ja [__] boot your
[__] door in tomorrow cuz you saying
some [__] you shouldn't be saying even
though the statue of limitations over
but you just don't want to wake that up
with other [__] yeah you know
what I'm saying so I was like man [__]
we all been through something in our
life in our lifestyles you know what I'm
saying a lot of people from my age
because we had no choice we grew up and
we had no choice bro we tried to work
you know it just didn't work bro it just
wasn't working for the black community
and I grew up in the black community not
with no Silver Spoon not with a gold
spoon not with a bronze spoon I grew up
eating with your hands bro in the hood
you know what I'm saying and in the
projects and on the streets with your
your best friends and [__] who turns
your enemies later on in life you know
what I'm saying because of this [__]
called crack crack [__] us all up bro
it wasn't gangs crack made the gangs
deadly gangs was cool I remember being
in the gang we we [__] fought we did
do a little shooting at each other but
we all went to school together that's
what's so crazy about it we all [__]
knew each other bro I'm from wats and we
all knew each other all around it from
the back street Crips to the East Coast
Crips to the Main Street Crips to the
Broadway Crips to the Front Street [__]
to the to the Hat game watch to the
Third Street to the Seventh Street grap
to the PJs to the Broadways to the Anon
Parks but when the crack come in you get
so territory and so much money start
hitting you you start turning you start
going at each other it's a it's a it's a
rat race and then it turns into this
crabs in the barrel type [__] yeah
everybody pulling each other down
somebody's trying to make it
out watch out [__] I'm going
instead of helping somebody get out so
we just start it was the drug era that
really made that [__] a lot lot a lot
worse don't get me wrong it was bad
before it it was it was violent [__] but
violent [__] went on in the history of
Life yes look at Al Capone and them back
in the day so don't just point the
finger at us [__] that this
this is what I know for a fact is
everything that's big today all these
restaurants all these Brands cigarettes
alcohols every [__] brand you can
think of was built off of some criminal
inter y a't that crazy it's crazy but
it's true some [__] back in the
1920s and the 1800s was pedaling pushing
hustling selling killing taking to build
this franchise that is a a a Forbes
company now you feel what I'm saying but
when the [__] black start doing
something making a lot of [__] money
bro it turns into let's make this new
case up let's make this 25 to life let's
make this case up let's make make this
crack case up you get caught with crack
versus a a key of powder cocaine the
crack is just the worst [__] because you
got a black [__] that done set
up and said man let's take this add a
little try that oh my
God
versus a party you know poter was a
party drug I never did any of it but it
was from what I know it was a party drug
party drug crack is like yo get out of
this house we got to get out of this
place yeah CRA crack CRA make your
[__] ass go crazy cuz I dealt
with him when I was young bro I used had
a police pull up man and just tell me we
going to get you or we going to kill you
and I used to say [__] you get the [__]
out of here tell you that bro I didn't
had I I didn't had police when I was
young pull me over bro and tell me that
oh you going got nothing on you today
but blah blah blah and I say man [__]
you man you don't got no why you [__]
with me shut your [__] ass up I
got a key of Co in the car right now I
put it on your ass and lock your ass
away from to where you get in tears and
be like well do it [__] you
crying because you notice the
[__] looking you dead in your
eyes telling you what he'll do to you
because that's just the era we grew up
in man I us know the police personally
by their name they knew me they knew all
my
aliases [__] I had aliases I come up in
a time when you didn't need a license to
drive you can just jump in the [__]
car and go bro pull you over you can
tell them my name is Marty [__]
be like well Marty you going to get a
ticket see you in court you throw the
[__] in the trash you know what
I'm saying so it's a [__] up situation
man and I hate it bro I hate that that
that you know I had to come up in the
the [__] up part of it I I I I I I
wish my [__] would have been different
but like I say again you know when you
when you look at where you at now is it
worth all the pain and the suffering you
went through no but would you change
your life no no I wouldn't you know I I
I I don't think I wouldn't but I
wouldn't want to go through that [__]
again yeah ex that's the first way best
way I wouldn't change it I going try to
do it again but I don't want to do it
again but it's like you're not doing the
biop pick but all those Hard Times LED
you to the opportunities that help you
know now how many people with the ripple
effect of you just being out to the
world like that that in of itself can
make it worth it
yeah hell yeah bro you know like you
know when when you when I was shooting
Grand Theft Auto man it was like um
Rockstar to me and I give Rockstar these
Praises man because they gave me
something to change my life and change
my life for the better and for good and
I don't have to look back I don't have
to worry about doing certain things that
I used to do cuz it just gave me a
mentality of I have something to work
for
and it wasn't like I was making a whole
lot of money filming the game I was
making enough to pay my bills and stuff
but dude I was flying in New York
hanging around other cultures and other
nationalities and getting to see what it
feel like to be part of society outside
of this Society you feel what I'm saying
of just seeing your homeboys every day
riding motorcycles robbing stealing
killing cuz that and I hate to put that
stigma on my homeboy and my culture and
my my peers and [__] but that's a lot of
us was doing that a lot like probably
75% of us was still in the streets
hustling taking figuring a way out and I
don't knock them I don't knock none of
my homeboys for doing what they were
doing you know what I'm saying some of
us made it out and and did good [__]
with life man you know start trucking
companies bought property um build
property just went and moved on you know
and some of them went and got
professional jobs and and they did
better in their life you know what I'm
saying and they and they doing good now
and I'm happy for them but a lot of
us stuck was stuck bro so when I got
with with with Rockstar man like I told
you man they they they they help me out
of a situation that I felt indebted to
them like you know I was telling y'all
off records man you know I was dealing
with something um legal wise and uh
facing time and
they they gave me a better route bro
they came and gave me a second chance at
getting my [__] together and then you
know you start looking at your wife and
your kids and you start wearing the
options fast money slow good money safe
come home to your family this is ain't
guaranteed over here it's definitely not
guaranteed you can come back in a body
bag or you can come back with handcuffs
on you know what I'm saying or you can
go do something that a Karma would chase
you down and we'll catch you eventually
so I just said you know what let me go
and work for this company and film this
[__] soall game that they trick me
with you [__] Rockstar man but I love
y'all man told me the game was called
Paradise you said for what months right
oh no a year a year about a year
bro I I can't honestly
say a solid year or or longer than a
year but it was long as a [__]
that I thought I was was filming
something else and why so secretive
though oh come on dog that's [__]
Rockstar man that's how they move if not
telling you you're the you're the it
it's it's none of us it wasn't just me
it it was the other guy Ned Stephen
everybody on set everybody that was on
set working and filming they didn't know
what they were filming man they were
just like we doing a [__] video game
so I was like the main one but it was
like
hey man I'm getting more of an enjoyment
leaving La for 3 weeks living in a nice
hotel they taking care of me I'm getting
fed three good solid good meals a day
and I'm getting paid by the the rate the
good rate that they were giving me per
day you know what I'm saying for 21 days
straight weekends off jump on the subway
act like a New York guy go to Harlem
hang out do a little shopping and and
and try to live by they culture meeting
new friends and [__] coming back home
like man get to come home for two weeks
be with the family now you done made a
check to pay the bills and pay the rent
pay everything go to the movies go eat
good meals while you home then hey you
get that phone call back it's time to
come back to work it was a repetitive
thing for three years and it was a great
thing for me it was a [__] the it was
one of the best things that ever
happened to me in
2010 2010 came out 11 yeah we worked on
it for about 3 years three and a half
years and it was the best thing for me
dog got perspective outside La yeah hell
yeah look at me today bro going there
and seeing things bigger than you like
wow it's bigger than just La it's it's
bigger than just La just being on the
plane being in first class just feeling
important in life you know what I'm
saying yeah you flying back and forth In
First Class you ain't got to walk past
first class no more and look at the
people doing their nose like yeah get it
get in the back
get your ass to the back boy n you like
scoot over watch out [__] yeah
you know so um it was a great thing man
so um you know Rockstar man they they
they they it was a game changer for me
man they changed my life man they made
my life just feel like a purpose was
added to it so it made me get more
like it made me love living a little bit
more bro that's a gift right there it's
crazy to say that but it's true to say
it because now you you doing something
cuz by that time I done found out his
Grand Theft Auto now it's like
man I can't wait till this to come out
you know what I'm saying I'm part of
this [__] you know so you're like the
rags the Richer story within it I was
realizing that this morning when I was
like researching and stuff like you're
the one that starts off poor and comes
up like Michael's already up Trevor
could give a
[__] you you represented that was in the
game yeah and if you look at Franklin's
story in the game I never understood his
story in the game because he
was he never was able to be
confrontational you know now I say this
all the time that Rockstar gave me a
little leadway to be me to let me be the
ganger that I was or or tie a little bit
of my street [__] into Franklin but they
wouldn't let me be who I really am in
the streets I'm a [__] fighter bro
I'm I'm a alpha male I'm with all the
[__] I don't step back from nobody I
don't run for nobody I don't fear
nothing but they didn't let me do that
in the game so it was frustrating it was
hard for me to get into the Franklin
Road for a while because I never could
be
like shut up [__] when Trevor
saying something to me shut your ass up
for I knock your ass out no cut solo
no no we want you to let Trevor be the
aggressor oh I understand you just say
you just be like all right man like like
I didn't even think about it when you
said that you're completely right the
cut I know exactly what scene you're
talking about I got to be but I have to
be in that whole thing I had to be The
Peacemaker and the nah n n n n n n chill
out man the only person I had a little
bucking up with was my comp man my Bo my
boy Lamar man they let me man shut your
stupid ass up man but he still outow me
you know he was still the aggressor in
the [__] talking [__] I'm the shut up
[__] I'm a patchy blood in me [__] I'm
Hawk your ass and no I just be like ah
yeah whatever man like the scene when he
did that that went viral I posted it on
my Tik Tok man 14 million views bro come
on man the BTS shot goes that's what I
was tellal that's what I was trying to
tell you the BTS of it it's like d this
is real it's it's different it's like
it's like pressing select and GT you go
yeah he was telling me that yeah you
just watch it from a little farther
that's why it went viral everybody went
viral this is real life 13.4 million
views in 4 days I'm that that's [__]
crazy bro crazy it started your Tik Tok
yeah you just started and it's still gr
I'm like what the [__] so you know just
the scenes with me and him man it was so
it was so iconic you know slink had got
into some trouble in the middle of
shooting Grand Theft Auto man and um and
he almost I don't I I can't say almost
because I don't know what the the the
powers that be behind me the the top
dogs were really contemplating and
thinking on how to maneuver around his
issue cuz he had got into a little uh
legal trouble and he couldn't make it on
set so we can finish doing our [__] but
I kind of talked to them and let them
know his it's a gun case man he will get
out soon so they kind of like helped
with him situ to get him out a little
faster
but I kind of ow slink
um and when I see him I'm I'm going to
give him a hug for this [__] because
when he got in trouble to me this is me
thinking honestly thinking I think
Franklin was was able to have get
written in a bunch of more [__] because
it put a pause on Franklin and Lamar
[__] so if you look at it now Franklin
is is is interacting with [__] every
main person that's why I say he's kind
of like the more he's not the main
character I get you could press and get
all three guys kind of is the main
character though he's kind of the main
he is though cuz he deals with everybody
Lester Devin Weston Trevor Michael yeah
that is true it's all hubbed like that
around yeah yeah we start off yeah and
look at the missions he Franklin go and
assassinate everybody for
Lester M you know what I'm saying and
he's stopping Michael and Trevor from
always getting into it with each other
getting in the middle of them hey chill
the [__] out man is we going to do this
[__] all right when we going to do it
you go over there I'mma go over here you
know it's it's like it's it's it it's
when you look at it cuz I used to ask
the director man I used say man come on
man let me open up let me be me for a
chance in this [__] man let me
be a little bit more me cuz they was
letting me be me at some point but let
me be a little bit more me let me be
that street [__] that tough
[__] at some point Soo cuz he
was a British British guy
solo Come on chill you're going to like
how the story turned out and I just
like oh cuz you don't know cuz you only
get pieces of script in time [__] I
don't know what the [__] I get why
they're secretive what if you're drunk
one night out of the bar like [__] you
know what happens I'm going to win in
the endend oh I get it get I don't get
killed yeah I don't get killed in the
end Michael Trevor nobody AB orc they
don't kill me I'm Franklin I voice in
this new gang so it's so secretive ndas
on top of ndas and and I understand why
they doing it because if you look at
this people always want to ask me a
bunch about cuz y'all going to ask me
about six and I know it but it's you
can't say nothing these [__] is
invest in a lot of [__] money and
time and effort into making one of the
most prestige top games in life the
biggest see what I'm saying is the
biggest game ever see what I'm saying so
that's how they are they real top secret
they stealth like I tell people they
they just like they just sitting over
you like a stealth plane man and they
just making sure you're not doing
nothing to jeopardize their investment
you know what I'm saying wow so your
paperwork that NDA holds over your
[__] head you can you can get sued
you can be in trouble and you can't win
against them no they'll take you to
court for for 18 years straight you
broke you'll lose your house lose
everything they a paying you no more
they ain't giving you no more money so
you know it's just being smart and it's
being a team member you know and that's
what end up happening with me and
Rockstar man we we end up turning into u
a great relationship between us you know
whether whether however it turns out in
the end in the in the end of it with me
or whatever we just we tied in we locked
in I know they care about me I know they
care about me and I care about them
personally some of them person I don't
know them all but I know some of the
main ones and I can talk to them on the
phone I can shoot them a text or I can
say hey give me a call cuz I know they
busy but they will call back you know
what I'm saying and they and they always
looking out for me they keeping me doing
something some type of work at the end
of the day I I want to work for them I
want to hey do y'all have any kind of
job that I can be employed in to help
maybe I can help with the helping people
on that lingo of talking like a [__] you
know what I'm saying I can teach him how
to be Hood I can do this or I can scout
what y'all looking for basically What DJ
PO is doing grabbing you guys yeah cuz
DJ po he's man that dude boy he's a
grinder man he's nonstop man Grinder Man
you know he he he got some [__] on the
table right now that um I think the
approval came the wash um a TV series S
no [__] and we fa we F to shoot a TV
series to the watch man so they bringing
us back I think Snoop and Dre might be
coming back but I know me and him for
sure and it's going to be room for other
people y'all some coming into the watch
type [__] you know new people but it's a
TV series so it can keep going episode
this episode that Season 2 Season 3 so
he he he keep DJ poop keeps his [__]
hand and his brain working and sometime
I get a little upset with him because
but he just been this way all the time
like he he he's always too busy
for he's [__] too busy for himself
it's like I want to tell rockstar hey
look just pay me to babysit poo and keep
him on track because he don't
intentionally not return calls or not
show up to meetings or not be on point
he's his his brain man I'm talking about
this dude can jump on the phone right
now hey give me five minutes man let me
I got to take this important call and he
will [__] around take off walking and be
on the one t freeway just walking
[__] by his on the phone bro I'm
telling you he get lost and you got to
go and find him hey bro we all waiting
the film oh [__] U I got to call you
right back oh yeah I'm the director I
wrote
this yeah yeah so so yeah and um that's
he's a he's a he's a hardworking man
he's a blessed man he's a blessing to a
lot of people um I I owe him enough and
that's why I always give him his flowers
on all my interviews man I always beg
him just give him all his praise man
because he's never selfish he's always
the opportunities of for anybody if
you're around him or anything and you he
going to give you opportunity it ain't
guarantee you'll get it but he's going
to give you the opportunity man read for
it come on dog hey come up here today we
doing this come come and a lot of us
that were close around him ended up you
know doing some [__] off of his coil so
I give him his flowers all the time man
and po know how I feel about him you
know he know it's a mutual love between
us you know what I'm saying and um since
the 80s he's been connecting dots and
making [__] happen it seems like like do
they need now you talking about a bio
mov do a movie do a bio pick on DJ poo
people be surprised just going like
looking at his credential like wait what
what God you did this L coj like you
said it like he's the West Coast Spike
Lee that's what you said last time he's
the West Coast Spike Lee but also the
West Coast
um like DJ Premiere or some [__] bro cuz
his hands is tied in with every big
artist that's out Tupac Snoop Dre Cube M
dubsy cam you just MC anybody that's a
rapper pu and did some music for them he
done produce songs and songs on top of
songs his voices on everything king T
you know him and king T was like this if
you look at the first king T album DJ P
king T right there together P he's he's
a legend man he's a [__] Legend on
top of a legend to me man and he don't
get his n praise man and I don't think
and reason he don't get it he get it but
I don't think he he get it like he
should get it like he should be getting
a award at one of these you know them
legendary Awards them Lifetime
Achievement Award I I would love to see
them do him like that because he
he he don't ask for it he don't ask
nobody for nothing man he don't ask
nobody for [__] and when he do ask
because he really need it you know if he
call you and say I need you man and I
need this and I need I need some help
get off your ass and give it to him yeah
because trust me he's going he's it's
going it's going it's a good investment
DJ poo wore push trees outfit on the
first Dr Dre podcast like n years ago
and never even asked him [__] like I
never even asked him he just sent me a
text I'll check it
out what the hell is by the way here's a
paper you got to sign for Apple music so
you can I can wear it yeah yeah like yo
I love you man I even ask you dude like
[__] like that I knew you for six months
SM I chill with you and like you wor on
the Dr Dre show I love you man yeah just
sit like that like you didn't have to do
that for me yeah at all you did not have
to do that for me you did yeah p is that
kind of guy man I like that kind of guy
always going to be cool he's always
going to be cool man I love him it's
nothing I wouldn't do for him nothing
I'm being honest with you man I can look
a [__] in the face man if
he I don't give a [__] if the police
looking or not if he called a hit in I'm
going bro I'm putting mine on the line
for that dude cuz he's he's that's my
guy I love him to death man so it is
what it is and for somebody that's so
comfortable behind the scenes like
you're saying it's like a lot of people
might not even be aware of this you got
to really like let the world know about
it cuz he's not trying to be a superstar
and that's why I give him his flowers
all the time so wake your minds up to
what he's actually done mhm you know one
of the most iconic um um Hood Classics
Friday co- wrote that with Ice Cube man
you know what I'm saying crazy BR wow he
wasn't just in it talking about this my
grandama chain and and acting like he
was acting no he was Tarantino of the
[__] yeah yeah his vision is is crazy as
hell it's funny it's crazy but it's
funny I used always say man man I used
to be thinking my head man when you
going to do a [__] serious movie but
Vision who just liked to make people
laugh man he just want people happy do
it for 35 years yeah I don't think I
don't think I think he'll [__] uh Denzel
Washington and um and um um Morgan
Freeman and um Samuel Jackson he [__]
him up man because he had him doing
funny
[__] I got you I got you he won't keep
them serious he had them [__] I
just realized there's never been a funny
Denzel movie Never Never Denzel always a
some holy [__] there's no there is no
comedy Denzel he always and I think they
do great because people be hyped and
ready for that yeah Denzel always you
know set something down real
nicely and you got you got 10 minutes I
was wondering like what are you doing
this rubber band will be in your heart
be like what the [__] and somehow he'll
grab you and then in your heart
maniz yeah so you know that's like he's
Denzel one of my my alltime favorite um
actors man I I would love boy if
somebody to call and say hey you want to
be in a Denzel WatchON movie man I will
lose my [__] mind bro's your favorite
movie from it's coming God willing huh
what's your favorite Denzel movie A Man
on Fire man it's a good that's [__]
cold ass a good movie movie bro well and
then and then you I just threw Man on
Fire cuz that's something I can watch
over and over and over but you can watch
all the Denzel [__] over and over Book
of Eli everything you can just watch
everything man in the blue dress uh uh
you know the the devil in the what is
the devil in the blue lady in the blue
dress whatever with him and um Don
cheetah oh man got do your you got to do
your [__]
history oh you tripping bro Denzel got
some [__] man so you can basically just
take all his movies and just be on a
flight going to [__] Brazil or China
or 20 some mile flight bro and he get
you to there and get you back home where
you won't even know you on the [__]
plan I hate the planes I hate them
[__] I watch Princess Bride natur
I was just watching funny ass [__] and
the [__] next put a window up I'm like
come on [__] it's night time put that
[__] up yeah I hate people when they do
I want to look like what are you looking
at death and [__] yeah
I can't do it I hate we were talking
about it recently like every time I get
on a plane I make sure like all right
there's at least one white lady working
here we're good they didn't want to take
this plane down with you want yeah yeah
man go it's all Puerto Rican ladies oh
damn it all Mexicans oh we're dead going
damn it dude I'll be doing that same
[__] man I'll be looking at people come
on here like oh no no get off get him
like which one of you [__] got
the Grim Reaper on your show or [__] cuz
I'm going ask your ass to get the [__]
up off of here man but I don't care if I
cuse the scene I'll run off the [__] to
tell you you know a plane is the safest
it's safer than a
car it's easy for you to say that
[__] air going it's just a
little turbulence and you be like oh my
God man they be Boom turn your seat belt
on I'm not putting this [__] on
[__] you crazy we talk about this every
episode I know we do Dam I just got off
a plane so I'm like yeah man it I I hate
I got to get on one uh Saturday man and
I oh to Arizona man I want I be want to
drive I said man I might jump in my [__]
to Arizona still my
talk about the co-pilot that tried to
take down the plane and they had
to no co-pilot tried to like take down
the pilot so he could take the plane
down midair on Southwest two weeks ago
he's getting charged 187 counts of
attempted murder he tried to take the
plane down bro he tried to like get the
like subdued himp yeah everybody had to
like choke him out and take him down
what I would have killed his ass I would
have choked him like oh he died for sure
to keep the plane in the air I I didn't
hear about that good yeah I might drive
man I might say [__] it my back going to
hurt like a [__] we were in Vegas
and I don't feel like flying and I try
to get a car to drive back and they're
like out of state we can't give you the
idea
when all right I tried man I [__]
tried cuz I don't feel I don't know why
I just didn't feel like flying I think
I'm thinking about driving to Arizona
now just put your Tesla and just yeah
I'm thinking about driving down there
man just just to relax man but you know
sitting for so long
you're back it stiffens up but hey I
just probably make it a trip you know
what I'm saying just leave early make a
stop get out stretch get some air chill
for a minute that drive to Arizona sick
I don't know if you ever did it but yeah
I us should drive the Tucson my daughter
went to U OFA so oh you been back and
forth yeah pass pass where I got to go
two hours past it I got to go to Phoenix
so TUC sign is two more hours pass it so
not too bad it was like 4 hour trip 5
hour trip it's about a four 4 hour trip
five four and a half Las Vegas driving
to Vegas yeah what's up guys Merry
Christmas from Marty n everybody here at
dope as usual podcast shout out to raw
papers for sending me the coolest ugly
Christmas sweater I have ever seen it is
Christmas thank you so much for raw
being the official sponsors of 2023
going into 2024 this is just a match
made in heaven this is perfect we smoke
raw every day and we can give stuff back
to the fans this is perfect remember it
is Christmas get your stocking stuffers
go to rawthentic.com see every single
product they have or go to your local
smoke shop grab some trays grab some
papers right now do us a favor go drop
Merry Christmas from dope as usual
podcast go to rawlife247 on Instagram
let them know you saw them here on the
dope as usual podcast and if you ran out
of RW go to your local smoke shop any
smoke shop in the world carries raw damn
near raw is the official rolling paper
of the dope as usual podcast thank you
to Raw thank you to Josh we'll have Josh
back here on the uh podcast as soon as
he comes to La thank you guys so much
for watching thank you for supporting
and remember rawthentic.com endless
endless products endless information
just go check it out so let's get back
to this super epic GTA 6 episode thank
you for watching how was the uh reaction
to this release cuz last time we saw you
like this is the first copy it's about
to come out it's about to come out yeah
how did this goz we I mean I've talked
to you I see you talk to but I'm not
like hey so how do you feel about your
book release we're just chilling at your
house like it it did good man the book
is still selling that's what's so crazy
it's still I just looked today and it
was like more deposits and I'm like damn
like it's still doing an average I think
of about a 100 books a month or
something like nice but the first week
it came out it just killed it just were
you nervous were you dying inside when
it came out or were you excited no I was
regretful why cuz I was thinking I I I
done released my I'm private I'm real
private bro and I don't release
everything to the world because they say
when you do something you you in this
time we live in now you can't get it
back you can't snatch it back it's gone
you type something in Instagram boom you
can't go Instagram hey take that out of
there and take it out of everybody phone
it's it's over bro you know you can't
say like interviews you can think back
on and say hey hey hey Marty hey y'all
hey take
this take that clip out yeah don't put
that in there bro I don't want that in
there um but when you that right there
bro so it's it's it's it's things it was
it's things in there that to me I didn't
really want to put out but this
[__] dude that D you right
there he was like a [__] psychiatrist
or some [__] like I used to sit it was
Co time and you couldn't leave the house
so I used to just sit out in the
backyard about a pool at my other house
and just relax and he be in the
headphones so okay Soo so close your
eyes and let's go back in So when you
was this age you just like you spilling
the beans yeah and then you open your
eyes hey man did I say I shot that dude
man hey take that [__] back don't put
that in there bro you like man I got you
bro just don't you know but it was
similar to some [__] like that things I
was saying that I regret that I did so
sometime I be like damn did I slip God
you bringing it back out it's not a good
thing it's not a good thing bro it don't
feel good people the outside people
y'all will be like man we want to hear
your story
but the inside of me be like I want to
tell y'all but you might not like me in
this part or you might not like this
part of me or this time frame of me you
know don't don't look up to my gangster
side or my drug dealing side all that
[__] I wish I didn't have to do but I
did you know try to find the beauty out
of that book and a lot of people read it
and say it's a easy read quick read and
it gets to the point I had people say
they cried at one spot
it was really sad the beginning was
[__] sad yeah so I it was hard for me
to open up about that because my sister
which is that is her father that was
doing that to me she never knew cuz she
was a kid she was a baby if you remember
I said my little sister and I never told
her she just found out because of Theo
that's what I tell you I was
like and she like oh my God I didn't
never know I never knew and she's grown
with three kids and everything she never
knew I never told her my mom never said
nothing my mom took it to the Grave with
her so like I said there's things in
there
that you wish I wish I would have kept
the way that you met your biological dad
is the most insane thing I've ever heard
crazy huh well that I I pressed pause
and rewound it like I there's no way I
heard what I heard right now I did the
same thing I must must have Miss the
audio but on Audible I love it I love
that you're you're the one doing it too
sound effects sound everything is it's
great man it's great hey that dude used
did that man he put that together he
sharp man he did a great job with it but
that me meeting that man you know it it
was it was numb to me man you know it
was like who the [__] is who the [__] is
this dude you know and um cuz he wasn't
there it wasn't no love you
know yeah you fathered me with my mom
but my mom was a kid you know my mom had
me when she was young she had me when
she was like 15 mhm so me and my mom
always had like a sister right yeah man
like I used to argue back with her
Buckhead with her but I loved her to
death you know I I hustled in the
streets to make sure she had a good life
you know what I'm saying because I
watched her as a kid go through the
things she went through being on drugs
and cigarettes and pills and dating
different mans you know what I'm saying
and I'm seeing this and witnessing this
[__] as a kid you know what I mean so I
just felt I owed that to her because
that's the kind of guy I am I'm a
protector and a provider it's just in my
DNA to be that kind of dude so I just
bought her you know I hustle enough
money to move her out of the hood and
you know get her into her first little
like town home and then after that I'm
start making more money running the
streets and [__] doing what I was doing
and I bought her her first home you know
what I'm saying
and it's a lot of young men at 17 18
that have that might have did that but I
can contest that I [__] did it and
I'm proud that I did it to where trhy
yeah to where she can she at one point
could have said you know I owned the
home coming from a a poverty stricken
area watchs where there was food stamps
hard ass cheese all of this [__] I owned
the home with a swimming pool had a new
car refrigerator full Furniture front
yard birds in the backyard in a good
neighborhood next door neighbor is a is
is a white guy another one is a a
Brazilian guy and Multicultural
neighborhoods you know what I'm saying
and not just in the hood [__]
ambulams and [__] helicopters all day
you know and I just felt I owed that to
her because I brought a lot of pain to
her also man you know I could have lost
her and my sister if if you remember in
the book where the dudes try to kick the
D in because of the things that I was
doing I brought these
um dudes to my [__] doorstep
you know what I'm saying trying to kick
the door in cuz if if it was God's will
to open that door man to let that one
[__] screw open that door they Lord
knows what they would have did to us
they probably would have massacred us
all yeah cuz at that time you said too
yeah I don't know who it was trying to
come in there could have been my own
homies and them of the worst
[__] to come and rob you it's
[__] you know cuz he's going to
kill you cuzz he has to you know my
voice you seen me I can't just rob you
and say all right have a good day
homeboy you know you know I love you and
get the [__] on and we be cool I'm going
to come and and do some terrible things
to you so it it was like it was good
that they Wen able to get in there and
it was good I woke up that was when I
started around that time I that's when I
started my drug addiction really that
that I was in the room yeah from a
toothache it started from a tooth and I
was on back then they didn't have the
[__] they have now they had Tylen with
Codine oh wait you did say you told me
that that's all they had back then bro
so I was in the bed sleep me and my
cousin cuz we all stayed in the one room
me and two of my cousins one of them
from 60 crib other one from the same
Hood as me and um we were all knocked
out cuz we took Tod in our threes and we
was [__] knocked out but the
crazy part about it we were in bunk beds
we had two sets of bunk beds in the room
and I used to sleep at the bottom one
and a bunk bed is up here and I had his
gun it was a fully Oozy man and it had a
a a hook on there and I used to just
hang it right there at the bottom of it
and sleep and I and all and when you
sleep and somebody is boom boom trying
to kick the door and boom but in your
sleep you making that something else yep
you weird doing something in the in the
dream in your dream boom but all I kept
hearing my mom like I'm trying to open
it please stop the [__] police open
the [__] door and they kind of like
police
you know wake up hey hey hey hey [__]
wake up wake up police [__] we
panicking the police raiding the house
and then this dude said [__] open the
[__] door now it just D wait a minute
now boom clack clack he clack clack
clack clack we run come here come here
come here come here tell my momma and my
sister get up my sister was a little
girl told my momma come here come here
come here she was in her Rob they try to
catch us off guard come come come go in
the bathroom now this a tiny ass [__]
house this [__] house had to
been about 800 squ ft bro like a master
bedroom size bro we was packed in there
this is in the hood and come in the
bathroom and she come in the bathroom
her and my sister cuz I was going to
protect them with everything I had and
my cousin it was Christmas time and the
lights was blinking my mom hat to had
them old big ass lights that used to
Blink outside on the window you just
tape them up there put a nail and he
looked out the blind and said there some
[__] and my dumb ass just try to the
door open this way I TR I kicked that
[__] that way like off the thing
and ran out to that [__] and
just busting like a I was trying to get
they ass cuz I was just that angry like
I want to shoot one of you [__]
so I can pull your mask out and see who
the [__] you is and I couldn't they got
away they was hauling ass though cuz
they knew they knew I was [__] coming
cuz I was crazy as all our do they want
to catch me off guard and they was going
to do something bad to me bro I promise
you that I I I I know it in all my soul
bro cuz at that time that's what was
happening they were killing dudes
kidnapping them killing them doing [__]
getting the money you know what I'm
saying so um yeah so I owed that to my
mom for putting her through all of that
[__] that I was doing as a kid me and my
brother was putting my mama through a
lot of [__] my brother 10 times worse
than me damn 10 times worse than me God
10 times was she fully aware of what was
going on yeah yeah she was fully aware
of all I know your grandma was for sure
she like s where I can see you yeah they
were just all aware of it man and they
just let us do what we wanted to do man
that was the time right there around
that time that was the house I was in
this one yeah oh it's a Christmas tree
behind you right there yeah that was the
time that was like that was days before
that oh my God that's the person I was
right
there that's crazy huh wow yeah the
literal Christmas tree right behind your
head and the window to the left and the
crazy part about it is this picture
right here down below that's me that's
my cousin right there this little [__]
name was Terry he was from my hood too
but the two dudes that it was two dudes
standing there with their backs I cut
them out it was two dudes with they back
to cuz they never showed their face cuz
they was like some real Hits come to
find out them two [__] was the
ones
that now yeah
they both dead yeah so you were right
though if they got in it would have been
over they were straight killers they was
with the
[__] No No Remorse like I used to
hear them talking man and like I always
had a a heart when I was gang banging
like and we not doing nothing to no kids
no older people no none of that [__] no
innocent people bro these [__] shot at
us let's go over there and [__] they ass
up or shoot they ass they shot at up
these [__] be like nah [__] we
killing everybody and I used to be like
like [__] want to put a bullet in back
of your [__] head cuz you so
demonic you know what I'm saying so I
used be like no I I ain't going with you
[__] [__] y'all you know you
can call me a buster you can call me
whatever you want I'm not going there
for that [__] and then if I
found out that you did do something like
that way you going to see what kind of
Buster I am you know what I'm saying so
but it it was a [__] up times man like
I said money made us childhood friends
and cousins turn on each other we turned
on each other for that dollar you know
what I mean money is pure [__] evil
it's evil man it's evil but they made it
where necessary it's a
necessity what what your say it's a
necessary evil and money is facts you
can take you can take over the planet
with it yeah yeah everything we do
nowadays is a monetization type of
situation you know anything we do we
trying to monetize because we have to
pay for [__] you know y'all got to pay
for this [__] building y'all
got to pay all the [__] you spend the
time the effort I got to pay for [__] so
everything that we try to do we try to
monetize it to take care things that we
do and take care somewhat of our
lifestyle you know what I'm saying help
I feel so lucky because it's like I get
to do what I want to do and do that hell
yeah that's the whole point that we try
to put out to people to figure out what
that is for you that's a blessing bro H
yeah even you got to do some stupid [__]
you don't like to do and just suck it up
so you can do your do 10 years from now
everybody thinks 20 is forever I promise
you you're going to be 30 and go thank
God I've been working for 10
years I haven't been and y'all got to
get it out man get what y'all can get
now yeah but I'm going tell y'all this
bro don't don't hang in this [__] you
set a set a bar man get it get it get it
get it move on man and relax and retire
don't be no [__] podcasters at
55 60 years old still doing it because
you do have a show still moving and
making money no turn it over to some
[__] own it y'all get the [__]
go live the rest of whatever life you
have left don't sit here and wither away
chasing this [__] this is cool now but
don't spend your whole [__] life
retire at some point yeah and that's the
problem with a lot of people they don't
retire in this new world we live in with
these phones and these internets and
these platforms it won't let you retire
because you addicted we all addicted to
grabbing these [__] phones you see it
yeah people walking up the street
driving in cars and traffic looking at
Instagram like what are you woring about
what's happening on Instagram and you
trying to drive and traffic to get home
yeah so don't let this [__] consume you
man I've always felt like for me like I
signed up for that when I was 17 I'm
like I'm going to Sprint and by the time
I'm like 50 I need to be good cuz I'm
[__] sprinting you better [__]
believe it man make it make the
retirement come down they try to slave
you in the real Work World to 65 that's
a retirement time like no you work to us
till you're 65 then can get your
retirement [__] your retirement you keep
it retire 50 get the [__] away from this
[__] bro I wish I could I can't my [__]
started late this new life started 10
years ago yeah so I have to get me
another five more out of it you know I
mean I've been blessed enough where I
could have just said [__] it and I'm
cool start me a business somewhere or
something like that but I think I got
another five more of grabbing something
from this and I'm I'm I'm done with it
bro I'm done with everything I just want
to live I don't want to deal with none
of this [__] I want to deactivate all
these platforms this social media and
live a slow life bro it's these phones
and social media that's speeding life
bro we speeding through [__] years
December you're not wrong it's [__]
December bro we don't even remember what
the [__] July was I can't I don't know
what the [__] you only can if you go
back in your phone like oh that was in
July pictures and it show the date bro
so we have to put all of this [__] Bro
think about it I can't tell you what
month is what I'm you don't know what
day it is someday after I saw you I'm
like I'm going go check this out then
I'm going go film I'm go about to go to
base moving too fast Cal down man slow
down bro I get it cuz moving so fast you
you going to have an accident you don't
want to do that you want to move fast
get to your destination get out the way
of it man and chill out bro get y'all
get get it while you can get it now and
get the [__] out the way and retire bro
enjoy your wife enjoy your kids enjoy
your life relax watch how [__] slow down
when you're not walking in the phone all
the time it's crazy I did it last week
I'm it's going to slow if I don't got to
work I'm put that [__] there cuz usually
I'm like did I miss anything all I got
to reply to this hey just do this [__]
all in one hour instead of spread it out
every time I can can and what I just did
bro I went and got me another phone
right it just got my wife my daughters
my sons the immediate family I need to
talk to and important people I need to
talk to my agent few people at Rockstar
that need to communicate with me and
maybe like DJ poo and [__] like that if
they need me other than that throw the
other phone turn it off throw it away
until you use it until you need it and
deal with this for one week straight
just to see watch that [__]
don't ring that much M watch it just you
can
just relax I'm wait driving I'm like my
phone's on silent and I keep it on
silent yeah cuz the anticipation of a
call coming like oh God all right hold
on who is it all right who is oh I got
to deal with it it's almost like I wish
I could turn this off when I'm getting
my back decompression I can't be on my
phone yeah I fall asleep in the day cuz
my brain shut off finally and I finally
slow down you have to bro I don't and
I'm trying my best to to do that and
it's it's hard man the leading killer
right now bro is
stress we stress ourself out with so
much shz we trying to do so much in one
day yep you got 20 you got 12 hours from
when you wake up bro it's only so much
you could do you can't do it all you
have to just say hey to I got to take a
break man but see in y'all business this
is a business you guys have it ain't
going to work by itself so you have to
work that's why I say pick a line pick
how high you trying to go how far you
trying to go how much you trying to get
and say done I'm done man this is it we
should be able to live on this the rest
of our life with our investments and
other little businesses that we don't
have to be there and orchestrate and be
there to run it this is where this
Fool's been preaching since I met him
yeah I can't wait to make enough money
just go into commercials real estate and
sit at my house that's all you need
never again having a brand buying a
house that was like that first thing I
set out for now we're starting to think
about that what's the next 15 that next
thing we're setting out for set you a
goal bro go get you a a 10un apartment
building yeah exactly 10 units8 units
get you eight units bro and if you can
scrape up enough money to pay for it it
might in a good area might cost you $2
million get you enough money to get that
[__] get it out the way [__]
leaving $2 million in the bank yeah
exactly $2 million all I got is $2
million [__] in my in my
account damn that's going to be kind of
hard man um man [__] that buy that
apartment building because cuz that's
going to be income for the next 30 40 50
years for your kids and everybody you
can live off if you got 10 units and
each one of them [__] is $2,000
a month that's $20,000 a month if you
can't live off of $20,000 a month and
you already set you crazy as hell cuz
you got that coming guaranteed every 30
days for sure every 30 days and guess
what your $2 million is doing growing in
value yeah cuz your $2 million ain't
never gone nowhere but leave it in the
bank and watch what happen you ain't
going to get [__] cuz they done took it
and they done did what I'm telling you
to do with it they bought the property
you were going to buy loan it out
somebody your money somebody and they
making interest on it you ain't getting
[__] they ain't going to give you back
hardly nothing model for them though
tell it's a hell of a business model but
you don't have to fall in there you know
what I'm saying I want I'm going to take
all my money and spend it on something
that's going to make me some money every
[__] two weeks to a month yeah
that's what we need to start looking at
I'm I'm learning it myself right now bro
at the age I'm y'all younger than me bro
so do it now I'm telling you set
yourself a goal man so you don't Str be
dealing with this [__] for the rest of
your life because this [__] can consume
you cuz this is an addiction cuz y'all
interview a lot of good people bro and
it's like you probably feel you haven't
interviewed enough it's still some
people on your oh for sure on your
bucket list I have to get yeah it might
get to a point you might not get to that
top of that list bro so in the interum
bro get your bread think of a plan to
when you do walk away from this bro it
can either run itself you start training
somebody else another Marty another we
already in the works of this right now
see what I'm saying I mean to do the
show the back end we're staying right
here but to run the back end of the [__]
cuz what's what's over consuming is 16
hours a day working on stuff doing all
of our stuff I'm over here we have all
these other businesses we're doing all
this [__] and then oh yeah the product
that pushes everything where it's less
time cuz we have so much other [__]
going on when we can put the like you
said pick a line and focus all our
energy in one thing one thing so we're
trying to find a mini Marty to go hey
can you edit this while we're doing
another show so he's not stressed the
[__] out or while he's not doing nothing
nothing man he just sitting at home and
he relaxing with his family letting
himself heal because sleep and peace is
the number two healers that's the only
thing that can heal you really bro is to
relax
right now if you sit back in your chair
and you
go I fall straight asleep watch how your
body just go yes MH I know it's this
phone it's almost like an anxiety attack
cuz I'm like all right I got 900 things
to do again all right let's let's get
them done today yeah but you got so much
[__] you doing it interrupts your sleep
oh yeah you sleeping thinking about [__]
you your eyes is moving if you put if
your if your girl can take a flashlight
and put it on your eye I your eyes be
doing like this under your under your uh
eyelids while you sleep because you
still thinking on oh I wake up and start
thinking like oh yeah you got to get
that done that's not good bro but it we
have to do it because right now we in a
rap race everybody man cuz it's so much
money with this with this
uh YouTube all this [__] man it's so
much [__] money in it that it's
consuming us and it got us in this web
bro we in this [__] web it's just a
matter of when that spider going come
down and grab your ass so try to get out
that [__] before that
[__] Black Widow come down and
say your ass next to come up here and
get eaten or or I'll just be a [__]
black widow and be like hey man I'm
going eat up all these other shows and
we're going to [__] CR this [__] don't
worry we can just do that because they
will not keep working like oh you dead
you died from exhaustion don't worry bro
I'm [__] on my first win still yeah
that and then but it gets to the wait
till you're [__] 50 and go
yeah [__] fall from exhaustion I get
it I want to like you're saying just
just be done at that
point if you play it right and like say
the other versions of us the 15 years
younger versions of us they can be
hearing this right now like they're
preaching that and fools are like no 40
is the new cut off you be done by 4 you
know I'm not saying try to get rich you
can be lazy just try to get rich so you
can go live a life and not and not be
attached to all right a monetary thing
again all right you going to get this
money again all right I got to get money
again all I got get that's all our minds
is thinking like I was looking at the
little dude or not man
MH the more he's making the more he's
starting to like just do crazy
[__] yeah you can lose yourself man yeah
to keep it going you can lose yourself
trying to keep it going you know he's
doing pretty good man he need to some
sit back and and you know but I can't
speak on what other people's motives are
you know what I'm saying so his he might
have a motive he might have a a line cut
off and he might be on a mission it's
really hard for YouTubers cuz you keep
trying to outdo yourself and outdo
yourself and outdo yourself [__] hard
bro I'm learning with this YouTube [__]
and this twitch [__] man this [__] is
speak hold on speaking of twitch last
time we were here I was like you know
you should you should play twitch yeah
you know people would love to watch you
play as Franklin you did remember that
and then what happened it it and then
what's happening now and you're like how
much did Grizzly
make remember that's what we said like
hey bro I just got off with t Grizzly
too I got just got a text me and him
just talk to each other we we we he want
me to we fa um um well I'm supposed to
do it today but I'm going push it off to
next week cuz my mind is not really in
it but uh me and him going to do a
collab man good man oh people are going
to lose that [__] bro come on he he has
the gaming world with the his all his
homies too and that's what he does the
gaming and yeah it's a whole world in of
itself yeah he he he definitely like
like reached out man and like man let's
do it and I'm like [__] well [__] it it
hey [__] Beyond run it let's go he like
man I got to get you in here bro look no
[__] oh he just hit you up oh
wow oh he just left I haven't told him
but that F live a couple houses away
from me like he just left and every time
I drive by I'm just like and know there
was a time I drove by as I was playing
him like this is kind of awkward I'm
going to turn this [__] down I just kept
driving could you imagine
like you're a fan or something playing
right about my house hey T Grizzly is
getting it man he's he's I like his [__]
I've been watching him and following
what he doing bro it's fun he he
capitalized in the co time man he smart
man he [__] smart I wish that imagine
if that was me thinking like him in Co
time where I would be at be playing as
Franklin in my own world as of now but
you're a couple months behind man no man
I think I'm ways behind because of we'll
see my mentality I don't I don't have it
like them younger dudes have techsavvy
that [__] Mak that [__] frustrates me
yeah it makes me like bro can I just
lift some [__] up and I like hold it
from physical labor this mind [__] don't
work for me yeah Simplicity [__] we just
want to be CU we're not I'm not good
computers you called me after I left
your house go how do I how do I get back
to this that window and I go just just
click the top window on Google and
you're like all right I'm there like
damn that's how I feel yeah how do you
how do I turn this computer on like I
swear to God it's how I feel too I'm
calling LT all the time oh it's too much
Lawrence LT I call him all the time man
cuz that [__] is a is a genius
man he's he just hold on you say LT
Lawrence um the no helping him with the
world not not
not no I I don't think he's good at no I
don't think he's inviting him over to go
hey set up my computer LT yeah
tackle me I run the ball tackle me on
stream n this dude LT man that uh that
does the with your boy tone in there man
this dude he good man he know his [__]
bro I'm talking about it's scary he
comes to my house and I'll be like man I
want to do the heat crazy done look like
it makes me feel like I'm incapable of
thinking it make me feel stupid I be
feeling dumb as a [__] like just
I'm just pacing while he's while he's
doing [__] like that's what tone does
for me he said my stuff I'm like can I
help can I do something give me a drink
can't do [__] get out of his way exactly
he's like actually I got it I'm like let
me know when you're done I just walk
away I can't do this man you just you
just you just press this button it's on
go oh yeah but got you the trailer for
The Franklin's world looks so amazing
the way you de it was like a music video
was crazy yeah we redoing it though
another one I had to shut that
Franklin's World down I saw that because
because um this dude I had that was in
charge of everything
the no not another dude man that um I
got hooked up through through um y God
but um it wasn't his fault this dude who
we thought I put all the Trust In was
giving him money to set up build and do
everything he was turned into a dictator
in the Franklin's world we never could
get the Franklin's world to move forward
because he was trying to he was denying
everybody trying to come in
[__] was filling out
applications and he was like no you
don't you don't look like you role play
good enough you don't look like you got
exp I was like what the [__] so I start
getting DMs like bro I'm trying to come
into your world and spend some money and
get a business and this and that but
this dude is keep and I was like who so
everybody start telling me then my other
staff in there in the Discord was
telling me man this dude so I sat in a
few meetings and I watched how he talked
to people man it was like what I used to
be like hold on hold on hold on hold on
in the middle of the meeting with a
bunch of people like who the [__] is you
talking to like that homie and he's like
no I'm just saying Sean man no who the
[__] are you talking to bro don't talk
to them like that and while he's talking
to people people was dming me while I'm
sitting on the computer hitting the DM
man he's talking to us crazy bro we
don't I don't like this [__] bro we out
of here and you see you'll see my
Discord Community come from like 10
something down like CLE just dropping
dropping people leaving so I was like
you know I got to get rid of this
[__] so I had a contract with
him me and Rockstar Gams had a contract
with him but oh this was a serious yeah
it was a serious contract bro and he got
money up in front he didn't get a whole
lot but I gave him a few dollars that he
asked for but um I had a contract with
him where he was getting 10% of the
gross if anything come in but at the end
of the day I was building a server for
him he was pretty much the god of it the
pueter so I'm just there you got the
more blessed thing in the world you got
a server that I paid for and you got
Franklin in your server what more do you
so you should be the nicest dude
happiest dude letting everybody say man
let everybody in for free I don't care
let them in bro we need to get the
community popping and then we charge
after we get the community popping and
he see it different so I just was like
you know what bro one day I got mad and
I it was Halloween time I said I'm going
to fly into the world they having a
Halloween party in the server I said but
I'm mad I said I'm coming in and they
was like all right I come in there I
don't got no gun I said what the [__] my
character don't have [__] no more what
the [__] so I get mad I go to the
clothing store they like put on your
costume and come to the clo I'm tripping
out really for real I said where that
[__] uh U Jay at and he was like
no his name was uh but they know who I
was talking about he had another name in
there but his name is Jay I said y'all
seen what's it called and they was like
no we ain't seen him he around here
somewhere so I picked the phone up in
the server and called him he answer the
phone what up dog I say where you at man
he's like man I'm I'm
you you going to the Halloween Park I
said yeah pull up on me bro I'm up the
clothing store changing clothes so I go
in the clothing store I was just so mad
out my costume was just being [__]
naked I just took all the clothes
off I just took all my clothes off and
just had a mask on so wait you got so
mad in real life you set somebody up in
a video game yeah so so he pulled up he
pulled up and he like man you can't go
like that dog you got to go put some
clothes I like [__] don't tell
me what to do I jump in the car drive
[__] I'm mad for real he like
man you acting like you got an attitude
you need to go on back I'm going drop
your ass off I said you got a gun bro I
need a gun bro so we pulled to the gun
store and I'm like get out Franklin get
out go up in the inside I'm trying to
buy guns some reason I can't he was like
he was hitting buttons on the other side
making a way I couldn't get [__] I'm
trying to get a gun cuz I'm going to
kill this [__] I'm he was
knowing it he was knowing it I was going
I was going to Noodle his [__] right in
the car bro I was just to reach and kill
him while he driving and we just wreck
and die I was just mad right
so everybody this a video game we're
talking about a video game Franklin BR
it's a it's a
server Ser so so he he dropped he
driving and he like man he trying to
tell me some [__] this how mad I was he
trying to tell me some [__] he flying
driving fast trying to tell me how to
act I said man y [__] is you talking to
[__] I'm mad and [__] and I just opened
the door and jumped out rolling all up
the street [__] and then he pulled back
up and he like man what the [__] is
wrong with you get in I said get the
[__] out of here punk and he like he he
getting it by now and he like man he
just drive off and then I'm just trying
to walk around and mad as a [__]
like man I need a gun I'm talking to
myself at the server people looking and
[__] on Twitch I said man [__] this so
he pulled back up blowing the horn
p and I'm just looking at his ass and
I'm like man I wish I had a gun god damn
I want to kill this dude man so so he
knew at that point cuz the next day he
was terminated and he kept texting me
after that man like man is it true what
I'm hearing going around and I just said
man I'mma holler at you bro I talked to
you later but I'm talking to everybody
else like getting interviewing everybody
else like what's going on man man he
this and he that okay I talk to you
another person man he this dude act like
he just you know own us and [__] bro we
in here for free bro nobody paying us to
come in here bro he can't talk to us
like this like I got y'all man so after
I got rid of his weird ass he he go to
Twitch and try to bash me get on there
um Franklin Sean F he's a he's this and
he's that and he's this and he's that
and and my wife is like don't get up in
there he only had like
about about six or eight people in there
listening to his [__] I just I my
wife like don't go up and I went up in
that [__] you broke dirty shoe
wearing [__] who you talking to
you [__] you [__] what do you uh
categorize yourself as a female or a
male you I was just going crazy on him
bro I was like you lucky I can't touch
you bro and they was like he's like you
threatening me I said [__] I'm
giving you a promise you lucky I can't
touch you you never met him in person
never oh he's Discord damn he was you
[__] ass [__] he was screaming all on
Twitch yeah and then he caught himself
he was like oh [__] and he said it he
said cuz I my wife snatched my phone and
said get out of here you n you going to
make yourself look bad don't do that so
I heard him he said um oh [__] let me
delete all of this because Sean know the
top people at twitch he can get my whole
account um deleted and stuff and he
deleted everything oh he's a if I showed
you a picture of the dude you would be
like what the [__] I don't know what he
categorized himself as that's Rockstar
you oh you met him through met him
through LT toning them type of people
that was just like a online person they
never really knew him they never knew
him oh this guy's good he runs all these
Pages yeah let's hire him he know how to
build this and build that but I kind of
find out that he's a copy and paste dude
he wasn't a real developer now I got a
real developer I have a dude his name is
Dev X he's a real developer from Texas
and he's serious about his [__] he said
man this what this dude gave you before
is Child's Play to what I'm giving you
now gotta so I like man now the contract
goes over to him now and what do you
need and he's like that dude was talking
about developer supposed to get paid
$600 or $700 a day who said this the
dude that I got rid of yeah so my boy
said bro send me 500 bro give me a
contract we make some money I make 10%
bro I got you bro I really don't even
want to ask for that but I'm going to
work hard bro perfect a developer is
somebody rise with you get this [__]
cracking and then we eat then we all
make money bro but the the the purpose
of a server is so when everybody's in
the server you stream your personal [__]
and you monetize it yourself you in
there with Franklin so you need to be
doing twitch YouTube streaming that [__]
that I'm in here with Franklin and you
monetizing your [__] that's how you make
your money don't depend on me to make
you the money I'm trying to monetize my
own [__] with is hard you know what I'm
saying so it was just like he start
saying he promised to take me to he was
saying this all on Twitch he promised to
take me to to twitchcon this and that
and I said what I said bro I offer to
take you to twitchcon if I could speak
at twitchcon I was going to pay for him
to come there and witness I'm doing a a
panel but TW the people my connection
that twist said I I check with them a
little too late I they they plan they
[__] 6 months in advance so I said cool
cool cool so what was the reason for me
to fly you out there for it don't make
no sense one those man he's one of those
weird weird [__] bro so I just yeah I
just let him do what he do bro and now
he um he he he's he's now he's just
going to see witness what's really going
to happen bro cuz we clinked up all cuz
he deleted everything he deleted my
whole server bro he clicked all deleted
buttons just mess my whole server wait
after you after you're like I'll get you
get back to you he's he deleted
everything he had control bro you never
I pray I don't bro I pray he just stay
where stay at yeah yeah but we moved on
and he F to witness some [__] because he
he got out it it was like perfect bro it
was like everything worked perfect cuz
what I got going on now it's going to
This Server going to be so big because
Rockstar finally came and said we can
stamp our approval and our name behind
it now I can say Franklin's world not RP
now now it says Franklin's World 5m
stamped approved uh back by Rockstar
Games now I get the funding to pay for
big streamers to stream in there
pay for to be on these Platforms in the
front of pages and [__] he he missed out
on all that cuz he didn't had a patience
and wait and let's build this together
this is my first rodeo and I don't know
anything about this so just be cool bro
I just want you to get it popping bro no
I don't never want to be like T Grizzly
world that's how you always say I don't
want to be a shoot them up World bro
that's what [__]
RP fools yeah RP server is so you can
live this dream that you know you can't
do can't shoot somebody
yeah bro [__] full in the game but he
says this right but soon as we in our
server we killing each other I said bro
you just shot me in the head what the
[__] he found you in the game again me
no me and him we be at and the beginning
he was a gang member killing people and
doing all the crazy [__] okay but he
said no we want some immersive roleplay
bro shut the [__] up you want to leter
weird ass yeah he's a weird ass dude bro
I hear the stories cuz they do he has a
roleplay server and fools are committed
they are committed to characters they
committed bro but this dude man hey bro
a theater actor or something I'm telling
you bro the strangest [__] dude
I ever met in my [__] life he just
felt oh you going to pay me my money for
all but you [__] cutting and
pce ass dude you don't get [__] I'm not
giving you nothing your contract is
terminated and I'm glad I let Let the
Right attorneys look at the first
contract CU we typed up a contract and
when I put it to for Rockstar to help
with their attorneys to look at it they
say wait a minute Revis this and put
this in there you can be terminated at
any time of my discretion oo boom I
[__] you terminated done you can't
come after me and say you owe me if you
do another server I get a percentage and
I don't owe you [__] and then he went
live on Twitch and said and breached his
own contract he said and I didn't give
you the real name you think I give you
my real name on that contract good I'm
glad you said that cuz we recorded it we
got it that you said that V it's a void
contract it's voided period even though
it was yeah he's a strange dude bro but
I got this new dude man his name Waters
man Waters is he's a young kid that I
met through him and Waters is a diard
little young dude that's that's caring
um he want to see the server win and he
he's a like man no I want you to put
your name behind this I want your p
where you put your own [__] you control
everything bro you know he's one of them
type like don't put it all in our hands
cuz you don't know what might happen
with anybody bro so yeah W is a good
dude man I like this he's a youngster
man and I like him a lot he's a hell of
a role player bro hell of a role play me
and him F to fly into uh T Grizzly World
man we going to shake that [__] up do we
coming I'm kidnapping T
Grizzly I'm starting some [__] it's
going to go viral Franklin kidnapped T
Grizzly hold him hostage
tell all his homies we want a100 billion
dollar man and he owns that world so I
mean you if you that's like capturing
the queen bee n it's gonna be hard to do
that that that [__] right there t
Grizzly is a beast man he's a beast with
that that that roleplay [__] man it's
going to be hard to do anything to him
bro you can you can shoot him and all
that [__] up in there you know and but
to grab him man it's going to be kind of
hard cuz he keep little goons around him
in there it's it's it's kind of hard man
you got to come in there with a real but
you got to come in there with a squad to
make that Happ you have to got to come
in there with about 10 people with you
you know and it got to be planned
perfect to catch him off guard that real
life Heist yeah it feel real life bro
like I'mma have to fake like we cool and
all that [__] what up Grizzly what's up
man what's up Franklin yeah what's up
dog man yeah yeah come in I want to show
you this [__] man then that's how
probably we can get
him but do it before Christmas cuz this
comes out on Christmas I'm trying to I'm
trying to get this next week and it's
going to go viral it's going to be some
viral [__] for his and it's going to go
good for for me as well you know what
I'm saying because it's come on man he's
one of he's a top dog in this in this
server one only top three people that do
this yeah and I've been trying to get
with uh they've been trying to link me
with the dude uh kaai they want me to do
something with him but I don't know
nobody that got a connection with him
cuz he' probably love to do something
with me you know what I'm saying being
that voice Franklin yeah it'll be tight
and it'll help out with the server but
that's where I'm at with that bro the
server [__] man well that's good though
man it's coming back it's going to be
Franklin's world would you say R it's
going to be Franklin's World 5 a. 5m
there you go not RP no more cuz that's
what we had at first man a lot A lot's
been going on since the last time we saw
you man a lot of goofy
[__] I got a question so the GTA 6
trailer obviously just dropped it broke
the Guinness World Records 93 million
views in the first first 24 hours yeah
insane insane now I was confused cuz
it's not actually slated to drop till
2025 yeah is it true that it was like
leaked and that's why they put the
trailer out well that's what I heard I
heard it was true that it was really
leaked on a streamers yeah stream it was
really leak bro it was some really leak
[__] man I'm surprised that that could
even happen [__] anything is possible
bro [__] they hacked um Vegas remember
about a month ago all the season pal and
MGM Grand all that [__] was hacked hell
yeah prices was 2,000 a night for a room
and [__] like that it was crazy bro
these [__] can do what they
want to do bro if it's dealing with a
phone or computer or anything like that
bro so yeah with Rockstar but Rockstar
is pretty they pretty sharp they gets
right on that [__] and they they they
get down to the bottom of it they got a
team man they got a team I don't know
how who the team is and and how
aggressive they are
but I know Rockstar man you just can't
go [__] with them they one of the if
not the top video game makers yeah
around the biggest one so so yeah I
heard about the same thing about the
leak and stuff man but that video that
trailer is [__] unbelievable crazy bro
but what did y'all expect you know what
I'm saying know it took a decade it
better be like this yeah bro but then
technology is much better now yeah there
was no online gaming for GTA 5 when they
made it right
yeah is why it so long you think um I
don't know bro I think maybe I think
maybe because GTA 5 was still doing so
good this is this is me thinking GTA 5
was still doing good still making noise
and then when the online came it just
even went it was like a second release
come on it was second release for us so
I mean why cut the cash Cal you know let
it keep going bro it let it keep going
let it keep going but then I think at
some point they probably figured let's
get ready to go and I think it would
have been out sooner but the um the co
hit and shut everything down for a
couple years you know what I'm saying
everything got shut down can we see
uh
oh his server almost got shut down the
other day oh real yeah he does GTA
servers and everything all that that's
what he does yeah and it's crazy
rockstar I think they got something to
do yeah they and they got they got a lot
to do with uh 5m now yeah they cracked
down on him too yeah they they got
something to do with all the 5m [__]
what it is is like we run this entire
world we didn't even know about this
world no let's come regulate it we have
to come regulate our world they making
you unbrand everything like what he was
telling they told me from the jump you
can't do this and you can't do that and
you're not going to do this and you're
not going to do that and I'm like damnn
how can't have a Cadillac truck in there
no you can have it look like one but it
better not have no Cadillac [__] on
there oh okay okay okay [__] our
hardhead ass we was having Adidas and
Nikes all up in the [__] I was like I
was in the server looking at my boy walk
up with aidas on I was like hey man you
going to get me in [__] trouble
really role playing this bro take that
[__] off he like oh [__] I got aidas on
here run somewhere and click click click
come back with some big fat man Burger
Shot [__] on and [__] so I just like the
fact that you got so mad and you're like
I hate this fo let me hop in the server
talk [__] I'm going to shoot him the hey
that's what that [__] will do to you bro
you can you can vent you can vent and
that's the problem with it people bring
their personal [__] from their homes to
these servers bro they that's what that
guy was doing yeah they bring that
personal [__] to their server man and
you can't do that bro you have to
separate This Server [__] but it's easy
for me to say that man I'm I'm learning
that in this server world it's a lot of
strange people strange strange strange
so you got to you got to swim this this
this this Lake like real treaded treaded
you can't just go on that [__]
thinking you can swim with these people
hey man it's a little dude that probably
ain't never had a fight in his life
skinny as hell with some glasses this
thick big and everything man that's
[__] serious about [__] can shut your
[__] down or he act crazy or he's
something going on bro it's weird I'm
learning a lot man but it's it's
something that I really don't care to do
I'm really being honest with you I
really don't care to do the serice [__]
um I really don't care to do a lot of
this platform stuff but I just owe it to
the fans to do it I'm not looking to
monetize you know of course everybody
looking to make something off of but I'm
looking to just make it pop and I can
give more of my content to them on
YouTube and do things and let them see
some of the house but I'm not a big
person to show off none of my stuff like
if you notice I've never did that on
there I've never showed [__] because
that's my privacy and that's my world
you know cuz these people are serious
man Ned um the play Michael his house
been swatted like yeah I saw that man
cuz he's filming his [__] and letting
people into that world bro sometime you
got to keep them out of that world and
it sucks man it sucks that we got to
deal with that as being um celebrities
of the video game you know we get a kid
somewhere that just finds your address
your Tu my phone rings so [__] crazy
it's ridiculous bro I get calls man I
got voice messages man bro bro this from
people calling you bro I got some weird
[__] bro you wouldn't believe it bro
look at this [__] bro you going to be
like oh my
God I got the weirdest [__] that be
happening to me man I'm so I know he
going to show I'm trying to find it
right quick I'm so interested on what's
going to happen right now how you turn
the volume up that
speaker uh I your number
listen I'm not sure the right number or
not but I'm looking for Sean I just want
let know your number Deon line and I'm a
fan of GTA 5 but you know I just want
let you know um it's on you know if you
want I can take it down for you um if
not it's on
fast.com um I can if you want I can text
me the link take it down big fan of
Franklin you know thank you for do what
you do man appreciate
it he could have just took it down and
not but bro I I can play some of the
worse [__] than that we sitting outside
your house oh I've got that all time I
hate that [__] cuz I always look and go
you're going to get shot outside my
house that's crazy I go through it bro
hey I go through it dog I go through it
man me Ned all of us man because and I'm
learning now and start putting
everything in my LLC you know in the
trust man so that way they don't tie my
real [__] to me personally hard I had a
lawyer trying to take my name off of
certain people search all that [__] and
it's going to be hard for him expensive
dude it's hard I already started paying
for some of it I had fools dropping me
my address it's hard
bro I hope I see you and you wouldn't be
and you'd be surprised that you have
people that love you and hate you at the
same time how could you love and hate me
they're they're just insane they're
insane yeah I've had people I love you
so much I didn't respond for 15 minutes
you're you're a piece of [__] I knew you
were a piece of [__] I don't [__] I knew
all those [__] was fake you're just
you're you're a bad person like
been 20 minutes the [__] you expect I
was thinking about buying a phone and
get a number and just put it out just go
on soci people just call you hey call me
I'm taking calls from from 12 to 1 today
man just call I'm talking to anybody man
I don't want yall do it on stream don't
hurt me man please and and stream it
like yeah what's up man and let the
craziest [__] to me man that' be sick
actually it would be kind of cool huh
yeah yeah don't steal my [__] no you do
it it's too much giving them advice I
can't I can't I'm not Savvy enough to be
doing that kind of [__] now hold on uh
January 22nd you are going live live
autograph book signing streamly
correct
about.com fontino man um the tickets is
selling it's selling out that they have
to like put more to sale you know and
that's good man Ned did it uh about a
week week and a half ago mhm he signed
autographs for 9 hour straight
damn $40 a pop oh I think
he he made some real good change man $40
$40 and you know you're doing 20 in a
minute yeah so I'm not going to do what
he did I'm not going to go 9 hours
straight I'm just going to have a part
two man get a stamp get a stamp with
your name N I can't do that man cuz you
doing it live man and they want you to
write a quote sometimes this and it it
be up in there on streamly and you have
to see that and I sign it but I think I
might have to make a part two because I
mean God willing that I get that many
autographs you know get a whole lot I
hope I do but I mean I got a lot now um
and it ain't till the 22nd of next month
which is a month January 22 on
stream.com fono and it's in my link on
my we'll link it in the episode yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's on my social
media it's the first link up there but I
I if I get overwhelmed with him then I
do so many hours 4 hours and then I'll
say hey I'm coming back um tomorrow at
this time and I'll finish him up M you
know but I'm not going to be no 9 hour
straight Ned is [__] a old ass crazy
man that mother [__] 65 and he crazy
he plays [__] the fortnite he plays
everything I said man your old ass need
to be somewhere fishing or picking
cherries off a tree or some [__] he
fishing in for in fortnite F but you
can't do nothing but love him man Ned is
me and him got a a a crazy relationship
like a big bro little bro man but his
his um his ideas versus my idea we clash
with him but they make sense at the end
of the day I take him to the hood with
me I took him to the hood and he's
standing out you know n cocky dude walk
around and all these black people on
motorcycles and low riders and walking
around with guns and [__] and they it
was like just hanging out with him but
then the police pull up and they just
taking a picture of him oh [__] I said
what the [__] what they what you what
they waiting on you to get him a a SOS I
need help sign or something like like I
kidnapped you or some [__] like help so
I should have I started I should have
grabbed his ass in the headlock when
they was doing that [__] like and
drugging behind the car they probably
would have killed pictures of you guys
they taking pictures of him I mean they
were there not just for him though there
they trying to figure out what the [__]
is going on why this white dude with us
it's all black All Blacks function like
thousands like a Mot motorcycle club it
was The Rare Breed motorcycle club
weekend remember I told you I was coming
back from up North and I stopped at the
gas station yeah Whoa man I'm like whoa
a black biker gang you don't see that I
don't see that it's always Mexicans the
Mongolian dudes or white fools I'm
saying you know you see those gangs
which it's all just only white guys only
Mexicans only did the [__] the Vos no
we deep Bro no I saw him like all I
heard was stereotyp like damn you guys
are all bumping loud as hell huh when
you pull up to the gas station everybody
you can't hear your music you can't hear
your music they all playing different
[__] you don't know what to to dance Too
you just like what's he he playing Mary
Jane over here you playing Dana Dan over
here you playing Rick Ross I swear I
pulled up with nine stations going on
watch right now all full blast it turns
into a competition with them man they
they very competitive with their music
music man but that's just I've been in
the club you know I was uh the vice
president of a big Club a very big Club
oh really I know you you said you with
your homies I didn't know you I was the
vice president of a very very big Club
the Choppers man I was serious wow
serious serious dude with it bro is that
where the name came from for the dog uh
chop nah that's all rockar man yeah that
worked out too good come on yeah
rockstar hey Rockstar they they sharp
man watch this I'mma show you this could
we uh is there a chance we might get
another offshoot like the contract like
a Franklin series six drops right yeah I
really hope so man I really hope that we
can do another one man cuz that [__] was
fun I like to do that um I I think I
think Rockstar might they might reach
back out they might I'm me on servers
popping it's going to be kind of like a
I was the vice president bro damn bro I
always forget how you're a big ass fool
yeah you you like a different human
being when you're when you're a big ass
dude different attitude yeah right is
that kind of weird how old is this
picture [__] about 15 years old it's
weird huh you look younger now than you
do here hey I was a hold show the camera
just so people can see just so people
don't think I'm a liar hey I was a
bitter Dude too back then bro I
guarantee I had a gun on me in a
bulletproof vest guarantee is that why
you look so big oh okay okay guaranteed
bro
guaranteed damn and I was shaking the
hands of a of
a
[__] another a Mexican dude was a [__]
like Mafia type dude we was shaking
hands out a club cuz they was just a
respect thing these days man damn this
is this is right before I start shooting
on Grand oh so you're still in the [__]
with this this is right around the time
before I start working with Grand Theft
AO I walked away from this to start
start [__] with that was this was
probably the last time I rode a bike and
I separated myself I just quit and re
tired myself oh so you don't mess with
the no I don't [__] with that [__] no
more it's just too much man it's too
much it's too much like like a gang and
I was um in charge of a lot of
dudes
and and they look they look for me to
um to like have the answers for a lot of
[__] and these are all different
personalities of guys you know
firemen uh police officers all kind
dudes bro but you see the the street
side come out in this fireman and this
doctor and this off duty police officer
while they on the bike set you know what
I'm saying like you would think he would
be like you know something different but
they just want to just be a regular D
that sometime cuz they are police
officers fire men they just like us man
but when they put their uniform on and
they with they their Partners you know
they have to protect and serve SoCal but
they have to turn into this other person
man and um but when you meet them
outside of that man the coolest dudes
you can ever meet yeah I know a few
police officers man and cool as a
[__] man cool as all I know I'll
be like damn if they can all be like
this bro I used to say this a long time
ago
bro um this is when KDAY was popping I
remember I went on a show called
straight straight from the streets on
there back in the days I was younger me
and Cam and they asked me what do I
think would make the police and the and
and the neighborhoods respect each other
a little better I said well when you
start letting these good guys that come
from out of our neighborhoods that went
to go be a police officer that never
been in trouble but they went to the
service and they came home and they was
a police officer but then when they come
home you let them graduate the academy
to be a police officer but you send them
to the [__] Santa Barbara to work
let them police our own neighborhood cuz
we know these officers I got you let let
a dude that I know pull up and say come
on Sean solo man you standing out with a
[__] gun and drugs bro I'm going to
rest your ass if I catch you again bro
go stop this [__] let somebody weak can
deal with not somebody pull up and be
freeze get on the [__] ground
and kill me because I'm trying to take
my cell phone out and say or I got my
cell phone in my hand people that don't
understand me you know what I'm saying
they think oh letting um someone we grew
up or we know from the community be a
police officer it might be a lot of [__]
that you can get away with no let these
real [__] police officers come and
police the neighborhood and try to clean
it up cuz I can deal with a dude telling
me bro this ain't the way to go man and
you're dealing with a person that
actually cares about the place that yeah
man you know I'm going to arrest your
ass again it's your second gun I
arrested you last week man and you get
right back out in another gun man they
going to lock your ass up away bro for a
long time this time bro and I will
arrest you MH whether you like it or not
I know your grandama I know your mama
bro we came up together come on dog
officer Franklin wasn't looking at you
like that yeah you see what I'm saying
it's crazy bro and I and I can I can
remember and you remember in the book
that officer Franklin man that
[__] was a
Terri was it felt like Bernie Mack and
Men societ or Bo hey man he was terrible
he was a terrible gentleman man yeah we
sold dope and yeah we stood out on the
corners but I don't think you you should
have been coming up treating us the way
you were you had death in your mind you
had anger and you supposed to been upset
that we're out here standing on the
corner hustling but you also should look
at the ideology and the history of why
we're doing this in our circumstances
that we are in bro sometime put that
[__] in front of your [__] heart
don't wear your heart on your sleeve
when you working in the hood because in
the hood if you drive through the
project you going to have a 90% of black
young men and women hustling something
some weed or something because because
that's all the [__] they got so you have
to have some some sign of compassion to
deal with it and talk to them don't just
pull up with anger I'mma kill you I'mma
lock you away from I'm make sure your
[__] ass don't be here for that
little kid standing out there looking at
you they they that's how they think man
and Franklin was like that he I used to
hate that [__] man I used to
hate him bro I don't think I hated
nobody like I hated him bro cuz he's
that [__] used to pull up on my
grand mother my sweet grandmother and
tell her I'mma kill your grandson I come
home and she' be crying and I used to be
like what what and she'd be like don't
please don't be out there today cuz that
officer Franklin say he going to kill
you and I used to go looking for that
[__] I used to be mad as a
[__] man and he finally got what
was coming to his ass [__] with the
wrong gangs and [__] they put his ass in
the hospital he was a vegetable they
they tow his ass up cuz he you keep
doing that crooked [__] it comes back on
you man that Training Day [__] will
catch your ass you know what say at the
end of the movie it will catch it will
catch your ass man come on man everybody
ain't going to go for that [__] people
somebody's going to get tired of it and
they going to come together man so then
then we had some I had a white officer
his name was Conor I don't know if I put
it in the book I can't remember and me
and him got into a fight that wasn't in
the book no me and him got into a fight
man he pulled up one day and he got mad
at me and I was standing out on the
tracks in front of my grandmother house
where we used to hustle at and he's like
you can't park your car there and I said
man who is you and I knew all the police
officers I knew him by first names but I
never seen this white dude come and I
remember saying Conor and he was like
you got to move that car up I said man
I'm not moving that car you crazy we've
been parking there for [__] 30 years
and here you come around here we ain't
never seen you you want me to move it
off the tracks bro where else can I
[__] park at bro you going to move
that car I said no I'm not dog I'm not
going to move [__] now that's a bunch of
us standing outside but I was always a
person like that I used tell all the
officers take your gun and your badge
off let's [__] fight and they used to
be like this mother [__] crazy I was
like no I'll beat your [__] ass
guarantee you he did it oh that's what
I'm saying his name is Con that
[__] said what I said take that
[__] off I'll beat your
[__] ass I said you the same
[__] I catch at at nasberry for
of Magic Mountain and you'll be nice as
a [__] to me so he got mad I mean he
got red in the face and he took his [__]
off cuz I said once you take your badge
and disarm yourself you a civilian now
cuz you you you off duties now and he
took that mother [__] off man and I
whooped his ass but the crazy part about
it is the other officers had got a call
from somebody else and they came oh like
a neighbor called boy they came like a
[__] SWAT team and while I had
him on the front of the car he was on
his back I was whooping his ass and I
had one hand on him and he had he on his
back and he had his legs trying to wrap
him around me to pull me like he laying
on his back and I got him he got legs
trying to pull me and push me off of him
and another officer was coming behind me
with a billy club and was F to probably
kill me I don't know if you hit somebody
in the [__] back head with a billy
club don't know what could happen and
all I heard was and it was my homeboy
from grap Street knocked his
ass and they start masing every [__]
body we was all out there crying and
running and [__] ah police and everybody
cuz they just start masing every [__]
body and we all went to jail that day
that's when um uh s on police officer
was only like
$200 now it's just so happened I yeah
200 something time yeah bro oh scary to
be was he honest about like no we was
just shooting a fair one bro I'm going
tell you bro look I bailed everybody out
cuz I had the money in my pocket I just
happen to have a few thousand do it was
like six of us went to jail we they were
all in the sales crying we was all
crying cuz Ma and [__] and they was
trying to give us water we was in there
crying and [__] this is the local jail
that I've been in many time and I know
everybody in the [__] right so
so I said I'm bailing everybody out I
got the money on me so we bailed all out
we walking out so the next day um I
couldn't find my keys to my car so when
he had took me to jail he put me
personally in his car my keys was in the
back of his car he brought him to me the
next day pulled up I'm out there trying
to look all around on the ground for the
keys he pulled up and he gave my keys
and me and him talked real like for
about 30 minutes just chopping it up
apologize man you know he apologized and
and we was like officer con man and no
[__] we was cool and I think I might
have seen him once or twice after that
then I didn't never see him no more cuz
I disassociated myself after around that
time from that area I just stopped going
to my grandmother house over there that
much so I don't know if he either
shipped out to another area because of
what he did maybe Internal Affairs got
involved in it and moved him or
something but yeah man I had a [__]
straight out fight and and I and I
whooped his ass like you know how a
slave master finally put the whip down
and say come on you mother and you
like you just [__] I'm beat the
[__] out of you I'm beat your ass for K
so for everybody in Roots so that's how
I felt man and I whooped his ass but it
was a respect thing got the end man he
came were you scared when you saw him
rolling back up and you're like looking
for your keys no I I I I
at that time bro I I wasn't scared bro
police never had scared me they scared
me now because of who they are now cuz
they were supposed to kill everybody out
there that day if this was the officers
we have now oh everybody would got shot
we all would have been shot these
officers back then they used to come
talk [__] to us uh fight with us uh uh
argue with us and never do nothing bro
like cuz they couldn't cuz we used to go
behind the gate this is private property
but I can call you all the [__] I
want over this gate [__] you you scary
[__] and they [__] you back and
they couldn't do nothing we did nothing
illegal for them to grab us and handcuff
us so yeah it was a different time bro
you do that [__] now man you going to
die horrible death at the hands of a
police officer bro there no fighting a
police officer no it's over now they
going to shoot you you can't do it trust
me trust me bro we see it so much on the
TV bro that's that's that's a fear of
mine like because I know me I I got a
[__] up temper and I will fire on them
[__] fast so I try to be less
confrontational with with Police pull me
over anything man how you doing sir I
don't say Sir I'm let me clean it up how
you doing my man cuz I don't Ser you
unless you Ser me if he say sir you know
why I pulled you over I think I think I
do know sir yeah I throw the common
respect back for sure I Ser the whole
world I Ser everybody equally just I'm
going to just the whole world I'm like
is this whaty he used to be a police or
something I'm looking at him like
like what is Marty was a police officer
[__] Martin Lawrence was never a police
officer I'm like damn did I say too much
[__] now he read your book and he's got
some
discrepancies his last name's Connor oh
[__]
actually yeah but this this that that
was a cool ass officer man me and him I
wish I know somewhere in the world if
he's still alive and doing well he he
know that story too he's probably
telling people that story he's probably
happy there was some surveillance
footage of him just flailing around on
the ground with his
legs back then was no was no was no
footages like that nobody yeah was
nobody doing this and [__] back then you
know we had flip phones and and mot
shirts and [__] you know fck bck hey
where you at oh got you damn those
question yeah uh I heard you got back in
the weed I don't know if this is oh oh
that was the next question thank you hey
and I was about to say I I'm glad y'all
not smoking here no I'm not smoking man
I know you're not smoking but I'm a
closet a smoker man I smoke um I smoke
like periodically you know like if I
just feel like I had a rough day and I
just feel like I really need to relax
and I just be you know before dinner
time I boom boom boom go out in the back
and let it hit and go in the house eat a
good cuz you eat the [__] out of your
food your food is tastes amazing even if
your wife can't cook good that [__]
tastes as [__]
amazing but uh but my wife can cook good
though man
like Dam watch [__] n she can cook my
wife can throw down man she know I only
eat her food but um yeah I do it man for
the for the so I can go to sleep man cuz
sometime I can't sleep my mind is
constantly running and running and
running sometime you know we to just
marijuana just it'll put it where it
need to be just to relax but sometime
that [__] heightens [__] too man like I
had I had a pain one time and I smoked
it and it made me pay too much attention
to the pain it was like this
[__] hurt
so is a tricky game I think your mind
has to be set where you wanted to when
you hitting that [__] man y'all is weed
kind of sewers and I it's different I be
around people that smoke weed a lot like
I went to Snoop Studio I had to record
some [__] up there about three weeks ago
two and a half weeks ago with DJ poo and
all of them dudes up in there and it's
like the room was just like and I was
high as a [__] trying to lay my [__] up
in the Bo and [__] and like man let me
do it again C mouth and all that [__]
like the [__] man y'all done got me hi
in this [__] man and I was like
no I just remember you called me yeah
and you giggle you go I started smoking
get I called him immediately go you're
never going to guess what happened yeah
y I started smoking man so it it's it's
cool [__] I'm a grown ass man I can
smoke if I want I want I want to smoke
more but you know what I can't get over
I can't get over uh smoking and passing
out you just fall asleep yeah I go to
sleep and then I hate coughing that [__]
hurt man I don't like that [__] a
volcano for him Volcano Vaporizer is the
softest smoke you ever had in your life
yeah get me one I'll actually talk to
them about it it's it's cool it's a
thing you put the little weed in the
tube it fills up the bag and you just
walk around your house with a little
seat bag yeah get me one please
vaporized too so it's not like harsh
please get me one cuz I went to um your
boy spot and did an interview with him
what's his name
um damn with the long hair Adam Adam I
did Adam [__] did interview with Adam
and [__] and he took me over there to
his little dispensary right next door
gave me some pins and some edibles and
[__] for my wife and all that stuff and
i' be hitting the little the little pins
he be giving me some time you know we be
in the movie and we like sitting down at
the movie like here you want you want to
make this movie good yeah you sit in the
top right or top left top right away
from the door cuz the smoke just Rises
and it won't go in front of the screen
cuz one time
I hit my pen and you saw it on the
[__]
screen and I just looked around like
[__] dude everyone look back like oh
[__] man I feel so stupid dude you got
to sit to the right because all the air
goes up yeah it goes it doesn't suck out
the door go learned yeah yeah you got to
go to I pick theaters man the best one
that's I we we talked about it before
that's the one around the corner from us
is good too it's cool it's better than
the average you pick is the [__] it is
better and uh I just think it's
funny that I'm like I told you I'm about
to move I'm looking I'm looking for a
house and I'm like yo what's what court
do you live on and then I look down I'm
like oh my God I literally could see
this man's backyard wow just into his
backyard mhm but you're saying you might
move you might make a move right I might
make a move man hold on one quick no go
for it hey babe yeah but uh um whatever
the [__] you was saying she spending
more of my [__] money
can I spend it from the LLC wait man I
need to call her what you to buy [__]
purse or some [__] she get you in the
middle of podcast yeah man but she she
has control over all my [__] bro I don't
I don't control cuz she has to she know
I'll [__] give it away I'm bad with
keeping money I help people too much oh
and she knows it she said you too nice
you too J I can't help it that's just I
was raised up in such a hard life that I
like to help people people I like to to
hear here just you remember what it's
like man I wish I had a band One band
would change the world right now I
remember those days we talk about that
in the book though it's more like like
hundreds of thousands yeah bro I gave
money to people man this this book I I I
know like a lot of people out there
don't read books you know in our our
demographic our age group audible if you
really really really don't like reading
but you want to hear this story you got
to go on audible.com audible.com game
changers like the fourth one down I
remember yeah it's it was awesome
hearing it man it's a good list it it
really is and I I want to say cuz I know
you a couple of those times I'm like yo
this is horribly sad this is this is
[__] up yeah it's some sad [__] in
there man I I'll be sad re rereading it
sometime be like [__] damn you went
through all that and the crazy part
about it is bro it was so crazy that I
can remember all of this [__] like I
said this dude was cold that he pulled
this out of me because
my memory is bad because my childhood
was so horrible and you don't want to
remember that [__] so I forgot it for so
many years that I don't remember but
this dude pulled it out and all it take
is to pull a scenario close to it out
and then you can kind of start
connecting the dots back up and you can
keep going and keep going had you even
really talked all that out before nah it
was just weird who you going to talk to
about it yeah we just jumped right into
it like my daughter my kid kids they
don't they they they like read it like
damn cuz I never talked about it to them
they don't know nothing about daddy
criminal activity cuz I never put it in
front of them I always came home at a
decent time for dinner I always was
there when they got up in the morning
Daddy was never not home I was always
like I was like a kaisy SSA bro they
didn't know what the [__] I was doing
bro but I came home making like oh I
just came from the studio I'm tired how
y'all doing hey y'all yall all right
good y'all go to bed okay blah blah blah
go to bed get back up take them to
school hey take them lunch and and
between lunch and taking them to school
I done probably hustle this or took this
from somebody and then hey go get
something go to lunch then back home you
know it was I think that's what saved me
too that I still respected my family I
still kept them first I put them first
before everything and everything I did
was for them so I think that's what my
blessing came that kept me alive but I
think God was like yeah I'm a I'm I'mma
keep you alive because you're a good
protector and a provider but I'mma [__]
your back
up I said this [__] the day like I do
everything right God's like yo wait boom
feel this [__] I'mma let you feel some
pain cuz I you should have you should
have been called a long time ago so I'm
going keep you there let you old and I I
tell the Lord hey I would not complain
yep walking around your house your my
house is nice as hell just walking
around the house like oh my back hurts a
little it's okay I got stairs like I
never had stairs before I'll wake it up
the I get it them stairs be kicking my
I'll be looking up them [__]
God damn how many times I go I forgot
the weed downstairs oh my God man all
right I'm not trying to complain but my
back hurts man hey I'll be sending my
daughter I send and my wife man can
y'all go down there and get that you
know I can you walk the door I be like
oh my God man you got to come back over
so you come see how the now
fin is the Franklin bong a real thing
like in the house nah you
not something called we have a GTA B
called GTA B in my house before I met
you it was called the GTA B you know
what I mean and that bong look like
it'll have me [__] up nah it's it's
the process man I got you don't worry
God damn it's 3 whenever you're ready
you let me know I'll drive the 8 seconds
over and then I'll show you how to hit
the pH no you ain't going to show me how
to hit that [__] you have me
around this [__] looking stupid
but I think I need to break that that I
I got to bust that cherry in me as far
as that no homo but pause of the getting
high and getting super high and get over
it so I can enjoy the high cuz y'all can
smoke weed DJ poo and all these people
and snooping they can just Smoke Joint
after joint like right now if I was a
smoker we' probably be to smoke what
three four five
joints see we probably smoke hey we'
have ran through them [__] man
in here and still be able to do a good
interview for sure me [__] I hit it one
time and y'all smoking with the the weed
in the air man y'all be over here I'll
be like yeah whatever y'all
say man y'all order some [__]
chicken or something man what the [__]
man you know
so I got to get past that I think I just
need to smoke myself out I need to hang
with somebody just smoke me no I need to
come hang out with y'all ass one day
I'll go to your house you can just go to
sleep after and just get smoked out and
go to sleep anytime you're ready you let
me know cuz at you man you a bad
influence you said anytime you're ready
cuz you se you been my weed room there's
a bunch of weeds like I'm ready when
you're ready I'll leave you a ball I'll
bring you a r video want keep no for
real I think you need to come over you
and Marty there you know bring the wifey
come over my wife we just smoke until we
just I pass out y'all just don't do no
stupid [__] leave that should be my [__]
man you look up and people be high and
they pouring water on them or wiping
wiping hot sauce or dripping lemon in
their mouth no not me your wife no I
said [__] I used to see that on video on
this [__] this [__] put
fear in you for everything fall asleep
around nobody you be like this one eye
open and one eye closed man I promise
you I won't do anything to you while you
asleep you know how Brave I have to be
wake up and I got some
mustard man I'm not brave like that but
I got to break that mode man I think I
just got to get real I got high one time
in ey piic man oh my God I can call my
wife and she can witness a witness man I
was like call the amulance I Ain lie I
was so [__] H BR I was like what the
[__] I was sweating what's that a
theater was like heab tell them to bring
the food or something I got to get this
High down I got to do please call the
ambulance I hear my heart beating in my
throat I was like I'm too [__]
High I hit too much bro it wasn't
hitting me I hitting it and I said man
it's not working man cuz normally I feel
it and I hit it hard the next time and
hit it one more time and feel me I start
coughing like a [__] got up in
the movie Man man Bae something ain't
right call the ambulance tell them to
call the ambulance that's how high it
got but if I was at home I probably just
sleep go to sleep but I'm in a movie
theater and I'm panicing people like I
don't want to die here I want to die at
home [__] take me sleep is the best tap
out for that right that's all you should
do go to sleep close your [__] eyes
even mushrooms I'm done did you see the
sphere in Vegas yet nah I heard it was
it was it was it was a lot it was yeah
was you high of course that was a
stupid in my pocket I had [__] in my
pocket I was too nervous to even I was
holding on to my chair it's so high up
bro oh for real it's like 200 ft
straight up the seats what do you mean
it's like a hollow stadium and the The
Stadium seats all the way up on one side
oh for real ooh but it's the whole
thing's a screen so you're you're in
whatever they show you you're in there
was you tripping out a little bit I a
few times I look straight down I'm like
that's too much man it made me feel like
kind of like dizzy again yeah cuz
everything's so big you're looking I've
never seen anything imagine your whole
vision is just a world that they want
you to be in but you're saying it was
like 3D too yeah it was almost like 3D
it was almost like 3D yeah yeah I'm
going go yeah I'm definely going go you
should check it out you should check it
out I'm so before we get out of here
Game Changer you grab the book now your
your Twitch is coming back on right it's
coming back on it's going to be Rockstar
Pro Franklin's world m5m 5m 5m and uh
I've talked about it a little bit before
I was waiting till you got here I and my
YouTube man what's the what do you put
there I need the [__] subscribers man
I need to get my [__] what you what are
you doing um I just went on there last
night just to test do a test run man I'm
going start streaming man Ned is
streaming his s planing um the GTA 5 he
just streaming his self play GTA 5 bro
he killing the game bro 300 400 views
he's he's monetized he's eating bro
making good money what's the YouTube
Sean uh fontino Shan fontino on YouTube
Sean fantino YouTube bro so everyone
that's watching this is on
YouTube head over and watch some
gameplay all of our if you're watch you
like video nobody doesn't like Grand
Theft autoo nobody doesn't like it's
Earth every it's Earth yeah it look like
you know what you're doing on there you
got the three screens going you had all
the interfaces and [__] man Prof
learning I'm learning I'm getting it I
still you know the best the best thing
is just to jump off the cliff and say
[__] it put your feet in the water and
just learn on your own and try not to
call nobody unless you really really
need them that's I think that's the best
thing that I'm teaching myself now is
just what is this right here and click
on it like oh [__] that's opening up
another window all right let's drag that
over here click oh [__] you know that's
what I'm dealing with right now cuz I'm
so used to saying can you do this for me
hey FaceTime hey what is this Y and they
like yeah bro and I won't retain it cuz
I didn't learn I had someone do it for
me yeah yeah so you don't you like you
yeah you don't remember you don't want
to remember it cuz I just call you again
remember it like oh my brain don't I
don't care enough I got to care and once
I care I'm
like you get it yeah I'll start getting
it I don't care I don't care man I don't
care about streaming but I wish I could
just have it this button does this say a
word second camera perfect here we are
all right guys here we are take a third
camera perfect if you can just be voice
activated come on we'll be the [__] I'm
not doing this I can't remember file or
view I don't remember this just [__]
I failed computer class man man I failed
everything [__] man I don't even turn my
[__] off I just let it stay on all night
come back down oh everything still up
move them out oh [__] thank you it's
still up let me just go right into it
cuz if I shut it all down and I got to
wait for [__] to do this never know get
rid of that and I got to go back and the
mic not working and I'm like the thing
not moving what the [__] and I'm
panicking and [__] literally what
happened to me last time I said I'm done
with twitch my mic didn't even hook up I
did everything right I did everything
right you said still not working I'm out
of here [__] it I'm done with get back
on my phone on Twitch I'm full there we
go has a speaker in I'm done yeah I'm
over it man easy done um so Sean fontino
on YouTube yeah Game Changer right now
you can grab it I suggest you go Che you
can get it get the voice the voice the
voice for everyone in the car come on
you got a road trip coming up I was the
whole thing just stuck yeah it was a
movie to me I mean it is a movie and I
know it's your life but it's a movie and
um for everyone out there I was waiting
till you got here I talked to my homie
he said next Wednesday works for him so
I'm trying to figure it out oh yeah we
got some [__] so we got some stuff
coming right they they said yeah they
said yeah Rock's like yeah go for it you
can do it with this
kid yes they approved it we approved it
we're going to do some GTA skits [__] it
all right we're going to we're going to
do that [__] going go viral bro you see
that 12 that what is that 13 now yeah
but Tik Tok with ours like I can see it
in my head just going to be like a
10minute cut scene and hey bro it's
going to kill they going to lose their
mind they going to lose their mind all
the actually I got dialogue but whatever
Sean wants to say cuz I'm not going to
write out your words and [__] like man
whatever you want to say yeah no
whatever you got and then I can pretty
must take it and and I can get to what
you saying but in the way I know how to
say exactly that's like this is the
meaning whatever wants to say yeah I try
to write it out like that cuz this this
is hard it's hard it's hard me all right
scene over shoulder all right wide all
right a whole day and a half to write 10
minutes and I mean it's done it's just
yeah you get writers blocked and you be
likeu I'm sweating thinking about it
[__] damn just trying to think of every
scene don't mess it up because but when
Once I'm editing and go Sean can you
come back and say six words cuz I forgot
yeah that's dumb you know what I mean
yeah but [__] we we cool we're going to
get it done we're going to get done yeah
I know we are and and you know good
things come to those that wait when it
come it's going to come at the right
time the internet's going to go crazy
for that show come on come on come on um
so before we got here what is your
Instagram because that's where you're
giving the daily updates uh solo 118
solo8 and then the crazy thing about it
is that um I don't know who to reach out
to I've had Rockstar reach out to try to
get my name changed man cuz solo you
can't change it bro I tried to change it
and it won't let me do it it say
I got too many followers I'm verified
but I I need Rock I need um Instagram
somehow someone out there in your
audience or in your fan base could just
help me that know somebody in Instagram
Facebook that can change my name all I'm
asking is just to put Sean fontino I got
I got somebody that can help you with
that that's it oh that's crazy they
won't let usange name once you have a
certain uh so stupid certain stature it
looks like somebody hacking your [__]
yeah it says you have a lot seem to have
a large f changing this might cause
confusion contact this and I contact
them and they never get back I got one
guy he he might I'll ask him but any
help might try to charge and he's one of
those dudes any help or help he can do
it he can do it I'll just give you the
number yeah just hook it up and I just
need it done because you know I want I
just want to get away from that solo 118
[__] yeah that's I had started that when
I was in the street still solo 118 118
is my neighborhood that's 118 East Coast
[__]
and get that off I want to disassociate
myself with it so then also people can
come to my page a lot of people didn't
even know that I my page was the real
voice for Franklin they see solo 118
what the [__] is this dude he just got a
lot of followers yeah oh looks familiar
yeah yeah so I need that bro I get it it
makes sense though like solo8 has
nothing to do with Sean or Franklin you
know what I mean no it doesn't yeah yeah
where did come from just I'm out here
solo name bro I got I got that um I got
that no solo and I was a cold little
knockout bro a knockout artist bro like
I told you I have not lost no [__]
fights bro like I said before I'm all
wins zero losses bro that's facts bro um
I don't know how I stand now you know
with a [__] up back I'm going to shoot
your ass I'm telling you now [__] with
me but uh but uh the solo Come From Me
Ste in a um
you imagine that I will I'll pop a
[__] bro [__] in the car
with me right now
um um I stole a I robbed this this dude
man we was stealing on bikes and and
break dance belt buckles the long belt
buckles remember you just put a date on
this no the dude name was
school s c h o o l that was his name his
break danc name was school I took his
bike I took his gazel and his Kango we
just robbed these dudes right in the
hethorn area now we from the projects we
just used to catch the bus the RTD it
was called RTD all the way up Imperial
and you go ding ding and it'll stop you
pull a a rope and it sto and let us off
on Imperial hethon and we saw these
dudes coming from the hethon mall and
they sitting up on the thing with all
they B boy [__] on with they fat
shoelaces and theida and I was like I I
got to get this [__] so we just robbed
and took everything got home I had the
belt buckle and I was like damn cuz back
then they was they was calling me Yogi
[__] but this dude name OJ older dude
was calling me yog we going to call you
Yogi I was like [__] it I'll be Yogi so
I write Yogi around when I was young 12
years old and [__] but when I got about
14 I took this this belt buckle and this
bike and um got home and it was school
and I was like damn I got to make me a
belt buckle man and that's how I came
was solo I just took the because the
letters the O the L and the O and I said
I want to be solo and then I was like
that's hard and my boy was like that's
hard yeah and I was like I'm solo I
start Crossing out the yogi put
Solo Uh u i was from neighborhood [__]
then at that time and I was writing solo
down and um that's where solo came from
man it came from a a belt buckle that I
took that's the realest [__] I ever
heard there's some B boy out there
dancing with his pants falling down the
whole rest of the day thinking of this
full robbing him see he didn't have no
shoes or nothing we took I took his
whole break dance out damn cuz we was
break dancing we was trying to break
when we was young and all of that [__]
hell yeah he was Kango list uh Kango
list cazelle list Adidas list I don't
even think I could have fit his shoes
but I stuffed my feet in the
[__]
[__] Jesus CHR and then you got a you
just sit and turn around and get back on
the bus and go home type [__] no we took
the bikes and we just roll straight up
down Peri that's what we us steal bikes
all down there you know it was a
predominant like white different kind of
like upper class area so we used to
catch the kids with the better bikes the
BMXs the kol hars the red lines and we
used to go down there and take them and
ride back all way up Imperial Miles and
Miles back to the hood yeah yeah that
was our everyday almost like you like
you put a lot of effort you just keep
the bike bro you Rod 30 Mi for real you
know what all right you can have the
bike my parents B but also there's a
45-year-old instructor out there named
school that is just pissed off and then
they couldn't call they couldn't call
the police back you know the phones
was so who you going to call you know so
I know how robbing some kids is such a
wholesome story still I don't know how
it how you did that right now but it
because it because it was nonbing we we
didn't have no guns or nothing we just
was the bully you know sounds like
little San Andreas mission on the
yeah just take it off take it off you
know and fake like you got a gun and
[__] and all that you know what I'm
saying it it was just we was just wow
man you know cuz we didn't know no
better we we we was brought up a
different way you know I was brought up
with around all alcoholics and drug
users so my heart was already uh
championed like I was a champion out the
door like don't fear [__] getting beat
up by my older uncle and [__] so you
know just made me already be a go-getter
being around them cuz they were all
aggressive and gangsters and [__] so
always the reason I think I was like I
was because they were all like my my
heroes you see them on there his big
crazy ass and his crazy ass right there
man and um and they were Penitentiary
dudes and [__] and well respected
through the whole city and [__] so I
always feel like you [__] with me you
going to have to deal with them so it
just made me feel that way so I see that
The Knockout [__] it just happened that
just I just happen to have a [__]
punch you know look at these big
[__] not a small dude this been
broke so many times your kids are huge
broke my hands so many times you were
like they were like they sounded like
you're getting like recruited into like
gang bang like knocking fools out like n
hold on he's over here with us in the
book yeah in the book you did get
recruited I beat this dude name Sean his
name was Sean too he was tall he tried
to jump me in I end up [__] him up
and it was like could you imagine the
only person we jumped him in he knocked
us out all of us now he's the leader
yeah he beat us all up man what you want
me to say was supposed to been three
dudes but one tried to rush me before I
knocked him out the other two was like
you're in no you're in what's up
cuz you in like I know I'm in
[__] oh my God baby Mike Tyson over here
[__] yo so I know I know we're going to
keep it going but thank you for being
here man today today was fun there's a
lot there's a lot coming out and I'm we
didn't just just Hound GTA 6 questions
so that's good man like let it breathe
and the reason is good bro I'm glad you
didn't because you know other
interviewers they do that but if you sit
up and want me to keep saying I I don't
know nothing man I and even if I did
know nothing I can't tell Y how many
times do you want me to say that through
an interview get repetitive and boring
it's like it's like you get to the point
like bro you you can keep I'm not going
to say anything cuz I don't know nothing
to tell you why do you keep [__]
asking me and if I did know I couldn't
tell you so but people you know they
trying to get they s good content and
I'm glad y'all not like that man you
know you already know man you already
know looking forward though we keep it
we keep it simple diving into this cuz
yeah last time you left you were
basically like yeah last time you left
like don't worry I'm going get you a
copy and then
bro you should be very proud that [__]
was I mean to add that to my
my list of things I did on my bucket
list in life who would I never would
have thought I would have been an author
an author I never my wildest dreams auor
in other countries getting escorted on
the stages because there's too many fans
none of the things that we we do now we
never in our Wildest Dream I thought s
packs working for the working for the
city in meret think that we would do see
what I'm saying we never thought this
dog and we here we all here we you know
we accomplish something achievements in
our life so at least our name will carry
on somewhere you know what I'm saying
like your name y names is you know is
going to dope erir is going to be around
the podcast is going to be talked about
so you did something that's going to be
whether it everybody know it or just so
many people know it it still somebody's
going to know about it so you did a good
job soate back man you know what I'm
saying you apprciate it you're not out
here slaving a a day in day out job and
[__] you know they don't remember them
people man you know it's crazy that they
don't we don't pay homage to the
hardworking people cuz everybody can't
do what we do you know what I'm saying
so I always pay homage to the
hardworking people I I love to say man
[__] just keep going man you know I hope
you can get out of retire early you know
cuz don't let this [__] like I told
y'all beginning don't let this [__]
consume your whole [__] life that's
good advice though man what the [__]
could we do at 70 years old bro we we
talk about it a lot but how long are
these shows going to really go we even
said like in 20 years when we're done
like that's it I ain't trying to be 60
years old the point
is y'all show get better y'all going get
better betterer bigger cuz you got a
good voice bro appreciate [__] real
podcast interview voice y'all got y'all
got a thing bro thank I'm like damn this
dude got a real Billy D Williams voice
you know what I'm saying
yeah [__] I don't know why nobody from
one of these top radio stations ain't
hit y'all up it's cuz I say [__] too
much I said [__] like hey when I used
to sell drugs that's probably why we got
Mario Lopez coming in a couple weeks and
I'm like yo man how do you tone it down
for TV cuz when you if you heard him
talk that fool is East LA as he comes
and he's just hello today on was it E
entertainment news like wow as soon as
they say am turned it up yep and he yeah
B [__] so ex [__] you want [__]
what's happening that's pretty much how
I feel about all these fools on TV but
the the the best people is like that
look at Samuel Jackson you can't you
can't hold a conversation with Samuel
Jackson Steve Harvey or none of these
dudes and that's every word come out
their
mouth [__] [__] [__] yeah they
they just cuss man it's like [__] how it
is when we try not to talk like normal
it's like I almost can't yeah I feel
like I feel fake almost like I just want
to say what I want to say like today I
was like what do we we're going to
Spotify invited us to like a dinner
tonight like the new creators you should
come hang out with the people and check
us out and meet everybody and I was
getting my clothes again went I'm going
to I'm going to dress however the [__] I
want actually and I would got my [__] I
don't give a [__] be you I got some old
ass Vans I brought be you bro one thing
I know is just be you bro exactly but I
I I I learned something else too bro um
these these wrist pieces that we we got
you got got a few these are more of your
conversation piece right here you can
dress like a [__] shorts and
flipflops [__] look at this bro
that's weird it is kind of odd right and
and they respect more of a plain Jame
yeah because this says a lot just it's
plain he not trying to be flashy he just
like the art of this you know this is
wearing some t-shirts and shorts and
[__] it's like changes it you walk oo
it's just something different like d
That's that like I have five meetings on
Wall Street today bro leave me alone
that's how it make you feel bro and Mak
who is this [__] cuz that's the
first thing they look at like damn you a
house a house okay nice watch you have a
house in your but if he was diamonded
out the first the whole thing what did
he rap drug deer stereotyp I got that
with I got it flooded and I'm like every
time I kind of put it away I'm like uh I
feel kind of I've only seen you wear it
like three times I do I only wear
certain occasions is your is yours
aftermarket no it's all Factory see it's
a difference bro no I'm not going rapper
with it that's a different I want to be
able to sell that like down payment I
wanted one I wanteded A A A Factory one
done but they wanted more than what I
wanted to spend for number one but I
just wanted it to be but then they said
it was going to be a long ass wait I had
to wait a year just to get this bro it's
hard man a year bro when he when he
called me cuz you know they they 40s now
they not 41s no more you probably got a
41 I got a 41 yeah yeah you got the
older model yeah mine's like 2 years old
yeah two or three years old so n they
come this is new I just got this last
year I bought this for anniversary gift
from me um at uh at Santa Monica uh G's
Rolex right there Santa Monica but I
ordered it like a year ago and I kept
calling every month like hey man you
come in Eric he was like no you still
waiting man but we got this and was
showing me you know sh you don't want
something I just didn't want I like them
but I didn't want that to be my first
real solid purchase you know you know
what I'm saying but then when he called
you know I'm in the mix of building this
car I'm in the mix of building this pool
and I was like man I ain't got the money
now now you called I ain't got the money
so but I was like my wife was like just
[__] do it get it as an investment
sell it if you don't if you don't like
it yeah it's not mean I won't get the
taxes back cuz taxes you know but to a
certain fool but hey man just add 10 in
your head and there's the taxes but you
you can have it yeah cuz they they did
go up a th000 since I bought it was it
was a th000 cheaper on the website now
it's a th000 more M it's not 37 no more
it's 38 something now so I'm like okay
chill it's I made a thousand already so
but I ain't got no plans on getting rid
of I just like it as a piece you know
what I'm saying something for yourself
man it's a conversation piece too like I
said you know people just looks at the
[__] so like I said I'm saying that to
say man leave what you got on throw a
[__] rist piece on go hang out that's
exactly what I brought some vans in my
watch I don't give a [__]
and some joints cuz the one thing I
learned bro is when you try to dress up
to some [__] they expect to see
you like that every time from now on but
if you give them who you are in the
beginning bro then they respect who you
are and they know who they getting every
time they see you after that 100% And
that's all you want I want you to
respect me and and and understand me for
who I am right now I'm not going to come
in here all suited up and nice [__] went
to the store spent 5,000 on a nice ass
outfit and all that [__] that ain't me
that's not me bro I'mma throw a t-shirt
on some shorts and some tennis shoes and
the most you'll see is some new tennis
shoes on come on thank that's Mar I got
some new Vans this year that's it some
Air Force some W some Jordan on some
some Nike something you don't see some
Nice Kicks but the rest is something I
pulled out you know I'm not buing this
yeah or fresh t-shirt do this a bunch of
times that's it some shoes and fresh
t-shirts that's all you need bro so yeah
don't go yeah no we're it was just I
just thought it was fun like damn man
we're going to that tonight feel a
little prestigious and [__] tonight I'm
excited that was about it that's all we
got to do tonight but you're going to
stand out be by being you hell yeah and
like these guys stink like weed and they
pulled up in that car Jesus Christ
that's not they're going to like God
Jesus what do they do U but no I I
appreciate you being here I know we've
been here for a long ass time hey bro
cuz we family bro appr sh we talk bro me
and you talk side of this [__] so it's
all good we appreciate you rocking the
podcast gear out in the world bro I told
Mar this second I saw you pulled up on
me on the freeway and you went we had
our shirt on always doing it man come on
I love that [__] I got to give a couple
new ones man thing about y' shirts you
can wash them [__] and they not
going to shrink and they still feel good
man extra blank extra blank money right
there that's why we did that because
that that that experience like I love
keep it forever yeah I still got it and
it's still the same size and I put it on
and I still like how it fit you know
what I'm saying Hell yeah [__] yeah oh
before we get out of here what am I
doing it's Christmas this episode comes
out on Christmas oh yeah Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas everybody I forgot to
even say that can you we bought a new
PS5 to give to a fan oh wow could you
sign this and we'll just give it to a
fan they going to be happy what we're
going to do is like Christmas somebody
you got to follow solo Instagram and
ours we're going to make a flower post
it up and there we go
anything you want wherever you want it
yeah do whatever I guarantee you they're
not going to rub it
off damn look at that signature I'm so
excited to give this away yeah signat oh
yeah this man signed a lot of autographs
bro all my shit's dog [__] there you go
manit
yeah we go go boom there you go coolest
thing given away ever give away yeah we
just went bought like what are we going
to give it's Christmas
perfect oh and it's coming with the it's
coming with oh and it's going to come
with the game thank you thank you I
forgot thank you yeah someone's going to
be hyped man come
on yeah they going to be happy hell yeah
see that's the Christmas yeah I forgot
to tell you this comes out on Christmas
day so it's going to be a good day man
yeah you know I do this man so oh you
really know what's up where is Franklin
at okay h let's go come on that's
hard Merry Christmas F Merry Christmas
been a great year damn this the last
episode of the year is it yes there's
only 31 days in this year I mean this
month oh yeah okay what a wait you're
the man thank you so much for doing that
no no we do that see you sure well
that's going to be that's
that's if you don't mind that's for my
office's office man appreciate yeah cuz
I got the head shot you have a cartoon
head shot which is the dopest sh I ever
seen I had that [__] so sick you already
know now Marty's got a Smithsonian of of
stuff from guest and I love it you're
going right next to Tony Hawk Matt
byrons and uh Jim Kelly and DJ Drama
yeah DJ Drama hell
yeah um all right yeah good [__] damn I
almost forgot to what a great episode I
was just lost oh you're the man you're
the man thank you yes sir appreciate you
all right guys from everybody here at
the do's usual podcast Merry Christmas
from Marty from Sean and I merry Merry
Christmas have a dope ass day have a
dope ass day and I'm smoking
[Music]
weed
perfect
[Music]